Beck Lover, how terrified should we be of the Muslim majority in 2027?
I think we should be terrified about a lot of things, brother.
But the last thing we should be terrified as Americans is from Muslims.
Danny, on this episode, I beg your audience to stay tuned.
We're going to cover some very important stuff, brother.
For too long, the powers that be have been using Islam as a scapegoat to get away with the policies and everything that's been going on in the world.
And us as Americans, and I speak as an American first, not as a Muslim, as an American, our country didn't get here overnight.
We're in a lot of trouble.
It's literally the fourth quarter.
And my job today is to try to explain why there needs to be a serious.
Conversation between Muslims and Christians that really needs to be heard.
And really people need to put their bias aside.
Realize that there's all types of messaging out there.
X is by far one of the most toxic places I've ever seen in my life.
You know, the app itself.
And, you know, just our own history.
Danny, I never, first of all, when I came on the first episode of your show, I was not here to talk about Islam.
I don't, I'm sure you've done 10,000 podcasts since that day, but I didn't come to talk about Muslims and Islam.
Actually, I came here to speak about Albanians and their history and, you know, losing my family in the Kosovo war and walking out of the, you know, World Trade Center the day it got hit as a young man.
Bro, the first time you came on, it was such a shocking thing for me after we released that because all of the people I have known throughout my life that still have my phone number that are Albanian, they all hit me up.
They're like, no fucking way.
I was so shocked.
How close-knit the Albanian community is.
Shout out to the Albanians.
To my sheepers.
But just to give the natural progression of how that happened, we were talking about the lockdowns at that time.
Remember, the whole world was in chaos.
But I think what happened during 2019 and on, we have not seen nothing compared to what might be coming our way.
From energy lockdowns to massive global war to total financial collapse and so on and so forth.
I was on your show.
We were talking about, you know, natural things.
And that's when that one clip went viral about how I showed the word Allah is the same word used in all three Abrahamic faiths.
Whether you speak Hebrew, Aramaic, the language of Christ, or Arabic, that clip has gone bananas.
It literally changed the analytics on Google.
It was one of the most searched things.
Like, it was just crazy.
But it was to show that commonality and how little people know about their own faiths, let alone the faiths of other people.
I can tell you someone that's been a member of the Muslim community for the majority of my life.
It is by far the most attacked religion.
The most misunderstood religion.
And the most propagandized against religion on earth.
And I've noticed in all my conversations throughout the world, throughout the country, everywhere I go, on the streets, people that hate me, people that love me, I've noticed one common denominator.
Ignorance.
Ignorance, Danny.
And the powers that be and the elite that control this world rely on people's ignorance.
I beg you today on this episode, please go and look at the things that we're going to cover today.
Please open your mind.
There's a trap that's being laid.
It's already been laid.
It's already been in motion for a very long time.
A plan to make Christians and Muslims go at it.
Forget what's happened since 9-11.
Okay?
I'm talking about Armageddon.
That's where this all leads.
But it's not because Muslims and Christians need to be moral enemies.
It's because certain groups of people, it benefits them.
It benefits the extremists of their faith.
I, as a Muslim, can tell you there's definitely some extremists in the Muslim religion.
You, as a Christian, can admit there's probably some pretty evil people that call themselves Christians.
700,000 cases of assault against children.
The Anglican Church, as of last spring, the Archbishop stepped down
for covering up a scandal against 100 boys.
And there's been malicious things that have happened all around the world throughout history
and can all be claimed to one religion or not,
even though none of those religions teach anybody to do those types of things.
I have never, ever blamed the doctrine.
The doctrine of another faith for evil acts.
Yet it always seems, Danny, when it comes to Muslims,
their religion is always used as a way to dehumanize them.
And I'll give you a very clear-cut example.
Migrants.
For the record, I, as an American, never agreed with open borders.
Do not believe in mass migration.
I do believe in the sovereignty of the United States of America,
and it should be protected.
But if we're talking in terms of propaganda,
propaganda, the media,
every term you heard about, every time you heard a term of migrants, right?
When they were talking about the migration problem in Europe,
which Europe created themselves, by the way,
by backing the United States,
by destabilizing the entire Middle East,
by bombing the shit out of how many Arab nations, okay?
And those people started flooding on the shores of Europe, right?
So they created the problem.
People like Dominik Tartarski of Poland,
who would get on the news and we are proud
that we do not let one Muslim refugee into Europe.
That's great, brother.
I believe in sovereignty.
I believe that there shouldn't be mass migration.
But what's causing the mass migration?
Why are these people seeking shelter in Europe?
That's number one.
Dominik Tartarski of Poland and all the other hypocrites that are in power
should talk about how Poland, for example,
sent a couple thousand soldiers to destabilize Iraq.
So you were responsible for that country being overthrown,
and I was not a fan of Saddam,
overthrowing that country,
creating the millions of people that lost their lives,
lost their homes, lost their families,
places like Syria and this place and that place.
And again, not a fan of any of those rulers, by the way.
Yeah.
Just for the record.
And then at the same time, you created the victim and then you blamed them.
But what did they do different?
Look at America.
We've had hundreds of millions of immigrants come into the US,
most of them from Latin countries,
most of them from South America, from Salvia,
from El Salvador, from Mexico, from Guatemala, right?
Mm-hmm.
Those are predominantly what religion?
Catholic.
So when you listen to assholes like Tommy Robinson,
who, by the way, I just found out blocked me.
I guess you couldn't handle the heat, Tommy.
Who's the wanker now?
You fucking wanker.
Tommy Robinson, on behalf of the two billion Muslims around the world,
I'd like to personally send you my fuck you, bro,
publicly on the Danny Jones podcast, and I'm going to deal with you in a moment.
That's a guy- He's-
Yeah.
Who's in London, going crazy.
The Muslim grooming gangs, the Pakistanis.
Cool.
You want to call them Pakistani grooming gangs?
I don't got a problem with that.
Not all Muslims are Pakistani, right?
Mm-hmm.
There's two billion Muslims, Danny.
The minority are Arabs.
Did you know that?
Only 19% of Muslims are Arab.
Hmm.
Only 19% are Arab.
Tommy Robinson goes nuts in the UK, grooming gangs, this and that.
In my opinion, he was in the Epstein emails, by the way.
Tommy Robinson goes- Tommy Robinson?
robinson was in the epstein files was gavin mcginnis in the okay and they were saying i
think it was between him and steve bannon if i'm not mistaken if you could pull it up because
they're deleting them left and right now in the epstein emails they were mentioning how tommy
robinson is the cheapest one to pay off that's in the fucking emails shut up for real find it steve
oh internet please post this if i have not seen this oh internet steve will find it tommy robinson
was mentioned as the cheapest one to buy steve steve bannon i think was mentioned in that email
look it up brother because i've never made you work more in your life brother
no because the world's literally in danger brother we're literally in the fourth quarter we're
20 seconds to midnight as they say literally this could go nuclear if things go wrong okay
where am i going with all this did you ever once as an american turn on the news with all these
latinos come in and millions of them did they ever call them even latino migrants no migrants
you
illegal my did they ever call them catholic migrants hell no so do you not see that good
branding but but look at the look at the hypocrisy yes of course so something to be
perceived negative they'll never attach someone's religion even when that sikh driver whatever
killed some guy with the truck he made a u-turn the fucking idiot right he makes a u-turn everyone
remembers that video from a you know a few months ago yeah they didn't like broadcast it was his
religion why is it ask yourselves those of you that have this hatred for the u-turn
in your hearts ask yourselves why do they always attach muslim islamist a new word okay there you go
epstein says steve bannon discussed epstein and steve bannon discussed tommy robinson in newly
released files okay what they say is their screenshot i read it brother just go see if
there's a screenshot let's read the actual let's let's see let's get it from the horse's mouth
not this fucking columnist not this crazy albanian either is that an albanian who wrote that i am i'm
saying oh yeah we gotta bring receipts see if you can find an actual columnist
screenshot i'm not mistaken there was a quote of something you know he's the lowest bid base like
lowest price basically to get this guy to keep doing whatever he's doing basically sure okay
interesting internet put the comments go do your homework i don't even know shit about tommy
robinson what's his bent he's a crusader now in the uk and listen i get it if i lived in the uk
and our birth rate was going to zero because listen as someone that comes from europe okay white
and whatever you want to call it whatever the term for white people is is it the muslims
crackers is it the white people's fault sorry is it the muslims fault danny that people in europe
don't want to get married anymore and have kids is it is it is it is it the muslims fault now
i'm not even talking about migration remove every muslim from europe take them out completely send
them back do whatever you want i got a news flash for you europe still has the same problem
they're worried about being absorbed and not you know making another generation and
preserving the uk your men and women ain't getting married the institution of marriage
has been decimated not only in europe but here in the united states of america even if you were
true what is um in in europe in the uk specifically what is the is it mostly secular or is it really
is it christian is it christianity barely even exists in europe anymore really you can have
churches all day and i don't say this to offend after everything that's gone down throughout
history okay we're going to cover some of this between catholic and protestant okay centuries
of wars of wiping each other out mm-hmm and after world war one in world war ii it left europe
secular interesting after seeing that type of devastation after seeing that type of chaos people
just start believing in god bro they were saying why where's god right people always say where is
god쿠 he allows this to happen no right people always say why where is god he allows this to a
happenist no that is the way people got to maintain the church a lot more than the church
not the only one that crashed n Dabei, the library, the director for this and it женщin number two one was the north today.
no the question should be where you as a human being that was given free will a gift
by your creator to use responsibly and we don't do what's right we don't stand for the oppressed
what's this steve there you go cheap at any price this appears to be these are texts yeah
backbone of england says steve bannon so that picture is tommy yep okay so this is steve says
backbone of england and this is epstein i'm assuming in the blue yep that's why the pound
the pound is so low and steve bannon is cheap at any price at any price meaning it doesn't even
matter what currency he's that cheap it doesn't even matter if it's in dollars or pounds but why
do you put it in quotes backbone of england i don't know maybe to make it more emphasized
almost like he maybe he's mocking he's an important figure i got a news flash for the
europeans i got a new isn't tommy robertson super pro israel is he pro-israel like gavin
he's
i know hey i know he's tight with gavin he doesn't hide it at all okay he's over there
they just gave him a grand tour a couple months ago loves the place great go live there tommy
again i'm not defending anyone that touches children if there are pakistanis or quote-unquote
muslims that are touching children or seeing children or or doing horrible things to women
in the uk or anywhere in the world if they make it legally acceptable in the uk to punish those
people with death which is what islam calls for if you touch or touch a woman against her will
touch a child against shouldn't be touching a child anyway even if they agree to
right i would personally tommy robinson and everyone in the uk as a muslim
american if you allow me i will come and be the executioner of any of them found convicted with
evidence that they touched women or children so i want to clarify i'm not defending if these
things have happened round them up make sure you round up the protestant bishops too who conceal a
non-างlican religion base other bishops and
of all theseregardless can you so put down harold napologetchi back in the day
and hang on do you have such a language or view of religion in your head
do you Germain Boland should be the victim let's just do that coffee thank you
yeah jeff how is it going
man i really want to email it before well okay i don't i will after this is going on but i'm just gonnaentricaffedkoacal binoculars
and stuff. Archbishop Justin Welby
statement in full. What was his statement?
It was better articles you could pull up that are clearer, easier to read.
Welby, okay.
Welby faced
mounting pressure to step down after he
emerged last week that he did not follow up
rigorously
enough on reports of
prolific child abuse. Okay.
Involving boys. Okay.
I didn't see Tommy Robinson and the Brits going
crazy in the streets the same way they will because
the media tells them to hate Muslims and start
hell with them. Yeah.
They completely neglect the history of the UK
that wiped out. Why is the UK
letting in all these people from all these
other countries? Okay, so I believe that's a whole
separate agenda, right? That's global. We have all types
of different factions, okay? What we are witnessing over
the last 10 years has been a battle of the elites.
Some of them are more evil
than the others. And because
they operate in a pyramid structure,
they love the pyramid.
They love the pyramid. Only the top really
knows the whole plan of what's going to go down.
And I believe the top of that pyramid
as a Muslim
as I reach out to my
Christian friends is nothing
but the Antichrist himself.
He's the top of that pyramid. Yeah.
Every level below that pyramid
is expendable. I think the crazy part of what's
happening in the UK is
again, I don't know. It's birthrights.
I know there's a lot of, they're like flooding
it with a whole different culture.
So they're integrating this whole different
Muslim culture into
very liberal, into this society
of, you know, the people of England,
these secular people and who
are white also. And it's
it's, I don't know
what the
problem is, but I do know
that when you combine
that with crazy
censorship and clamp down
on freedom of speech and arrest people for Facebook
posts negatively about that, that
people post negatively about that immigration,
which is crazy. Instead of arresting those people,
that's how it goes out of
control. Even I as a Muslim
say the British
people have lost their rights.
The British people should have a right. Even Tommy
Robinson, with all his hatred,
I will always support free speech.
I am a free speech
abolitionist. Even Jake
Lang, the character that he is,
the one that I helped expose in the
film that I made with my brother, Sonny Faz, my partner,
the Muslim invasion of America,
and we'll get to that in a little bit, where we confronted
him. But getting back to
them, I am 100% a free
speech abolitionist. My family,
remember, was under communism for 50 years,
Nanny. I know what it means.
Not be able to speak. My family
was persecuted in Kosovo, where they were treated
like animals by the Yugoslav
regime of Milosevic, right? By the
Serbian paramilitary. I used to
visit them during occupation.
And as an American,
realizing how blessed I was, I would
leave them every summer with tears in my
eyes for two reasons.
Tears of sadness and tears of
happiness. Because
every time I left, I said, I can't
believe I'm leaving my aunts and my uncles in
these types of conditions, where they
never know what's going to happen. Police
will kick their door in the middle of the night, harass
them, shoot them, beat them, imprison them.
Everyone can look up the Kosovo war and
what happened in Bosnia, but
and then I would also be happy, because
I couldn't wait to get back home, bro.
And I remember hearing those
customs agents, you know, when I'd get
into JFK airport in New York,
and, you know, they would check my passport and say,
welcome home, and I would just be so fucking happy,
man. So proud to be a part
of this country, bro.
And how far we've come, the wrong
path, is really alarming to me.
So, to get back to the UK,
during the lockdowns, they had some of the most
totalitarian policies
ever, okay?
Which was a test run for
what's coming now. And the
fact that people are getting
arrested because they say something bad about Muslims,
I don't agree with that. A lot of Muslims
I understand, but also agree,
to not have free speech is more dangerous than anything else.
Same thing that people
in Iran don't really have. You talk against the regime,
you disappear. I don't believe in that.
Okay? And neither does
Islam, okay?
As a doctrine itself.
So the UK is in trouble.
And why these policies exist is
because of lobbies, because of politicians.
The whole EU project was to create
one country,
one united Europe.
You have one nation being governed,
it's easier to manipulate, it's easier to put
your globalist policies
in place, it's easier to rule them by the
United Nations. The UK
and every country in Europe should back out.
Of these agreements. They should go back to being
sovereign nations. They should enforce their borders.
But it's not the Muslims that are
coming there because they're being paid to, right? It's because
of all the chaos, it's because of the Middle East.
So you have to create war and destruction
and then you unleash those
desperate people into these territories.
We're being humanitarian. We blew up their houses
but we're going to come let them live with us.
Right? And you let that happen for a while.
But don't forget, you have a lot of Indians
and Pakistanis and Bangladeshis that were also there
for generations because they used to be under
the British Empire.
The British should go look in the mirror and think about
just how many Indians and Pakistanis
they starved during that time.
I think the estimates were between 20 and
40 million of them were
murdered by the British Empire. So they forget their
history very quickly and how
Christian they were. There was nothing Christian about the
British Empire. Okay?
Any asshole can tell you that. Any historian can tell
you that. But that's not what we're here
to talk about. So free speech
is in danger, not only in the UK, but right here
in the United States of America. Danny, I promise
you, if these people win, you
will not be on the air soon. Not because you're
pushing one agenda or another, but you're allowing
everyone to speak.
You're in danger, brother.
I'm in danger. Joe Rogan's
in danger
for allowing people to have these conversations.
We couldn't discuss if we
should put certain medical treatments into our system
and I'm still doing this shit because we were censored.
Not even saying the word.
And you're going to tell me we have freedom of speech?
We didn't realize, a lot
of us, that we didn't even have freedom of
speech during the
shutdown, right? I'm still avoiding
the word because I'm just trained. Meaning
2019 when they
closed the world down. Yep. There was a guy
named Dr. Fauci. Yep.
Still not in jail.
Trump's coming to save us.
He's coming to save us. He was anointed by Jesus
to save us. Okay, yeah. So what
I'm saying, Danny Jones, we're in
danger, brother. And I made a pact
to myself and God. I know
what my family went through during communism. I know
what they lost during the Kosovo War when I lost
28 people that I loved.
That taught me what it was to be of
Albanian descent because I was born here. I was born in
the great state of Texas. Grew up in New York City
my whole life. And
I know their stories of my cousins that grew up
in concentration camps in Albania under the
Hoxha regime. Okay, Andra Hoxha, may he
burn in hell forever.
That it is
better to die than to live
under that. A life without freedom
is not worth living.
So I want the Brits to be strong
and sovereign and to hold these
politicians
accountable. And to
do what they need to do, brother.
But don't take out all your anger. They
want you to focus on the Muslims.
They want you to be distracted by
that so they can enforce policies,
take away your freedoms.
So yes, the British are
in danger. But so are the Americans.
So are many western societies.
I will always be America first.
I don't want any country
to have influence over America. Even
Albania. Nobody should have influence
over the United States of America.
But until the American people unite, Danny.
Until we really
shut down the system if we have to.
Left and right
is the choice between Coke or Pepsi
and our nation's diabetic.
That's a good way of putting it.
It's a joke. And if you haven't figured that out by now,
you haven't gotten to the last level of Jumanji.
If you actually think there's a way out of this through
left and right, you're a part of the problem.
We are in
serious trouble. One side creates
the problem, the other one comes in with the solution,
but everyday American freedoms and civil rights,
civil liberties are being eroded.
Everyday we inch closer and closer
to tyranny. And it doesn't matter
who's in power. They all seem
to go the same way. They can't agree on
anything except more war and more war
and more war.
Forty trillion dollars. I have
family that served in Iraq
that fought in the battle of Fallujah.
My cousin Brian in Dallas,
he's a Muslim American. He enlisted to
go fight and defend our nation.
Ask him how he feels about it now.
Ask his whole fucking platoon.
The ones that survived.
Because a lot of them went down.
That shit was going crazy in Iraq.
I was at the 250 year anniversary
they threw an event in Dallas, because they're all veterans.
Respect to our veterans.
They all said the same thing to me.
I swear to God I shit you not, Danny.
If I'm lying, may I never get home, bro.
May I never see another day if I'm lying.
I regret going.
It wasn't what they told us.
We shouldn't have been there.
And they're treated like
absolute garbage when they come back.
Not by the American people,
but the institutions, their bullshit VA hospitals.
We leave them on the streets.
Used and abused to be
corporate feudalistic slaves, bro.
So what do you think about this whole Iran war?
I don't know.
Is it hard to think about how Benjamin Netanyahu
has been talking about it for 30 years
and he finally got it?
He finally got it. He's documented.
Run the clips if you need to, but they're there.
30 years.
They're this close away from a nuke.
I'm not here to talk about
the regime one way or the other.
I don't agree with the way they govern those people.
I don't agree that they don't have freedom of speech.
I don't agree in a lot of things they do.
And again,
they are a minority sect
of the Muslim faith.
They're Shia majority.
I don't really adhere to a lot of
their thoughts and their beliefs.
But there is a very distinct
difference between Sunni and Shia.
And practices
and rituals
and all types of stuff.
Things that they might make permissible
that the majority don't and stuff like that.
But at the end of the day,
you know,
when the Kosovo war was going on,
okay?
Pull this up.
It's called the Atlantic Battalion, Kosovo.
Atlantic Battalion. Pull it up.
All these people in the streets of the US
and Beverly Hills,
many of them of Jewish descent, no problem.
All these people saying,
you get the fuck up.
You guys get up. All you that want war with Iran,
you guys get up.
Get armed. I got no problem. You want to go?
Because we're giving out weapons like candy anyway.
Take guns, go liberate your country.
Go ahead.
But you're not going to send my son to die in Iran.
I got three sons.
Now if someone was attacking the US,
that's why I believe we're in serious danger.
Some type of false flag.
Imminent. I've been saying this for over a year publicly.
Okay?
They no longer repair their image, okay?
Pull up the Atlantic Battalion.
Pull up the brief description, okay?
There was Albanian Americans.
Albania's got the sickest logo.
It's one of the most ancient flags in the world, brother.
That's the sickest logo of all flags.
It's one of the sickest flags.
Because us Albanians, we always have to watch our back.
Greeks this way, Serbians this way.
Greeks this way, Serbians that way.
We never had a chance to breathe, man.
All right?
So all you guys in Beverly Hills,
all you guys in California,
and you're dying for this war with Iran.
And listen to me.
I've been to protest for Iran for women's rights
like when they killed that one poor girl
because her head covering was off.
I was with Maz Jabroni.
It's on my Instagram. All of you go.
Go scroll down.
I was with Maz Jabroni.
He's one of the most famous Persian comedians.
My brother Tehran, also a legend in Los Angeles.
And you could always find those two brothers of mine
at the Laugh Factory in LA right on Sunset Boulevard.
So they ended up taking me to a protest, bro.
Because you never know
if they have intelligence people here
or stuff like that, you know, assassins.
You don't know.
So I'm just standing behind the whole time like,
I hope I don't get shot in the back of my eye.
Why am I in an Iranian-American protest right now?
Is what I'm thinking.
And then the next day, you know what Maz Jabroni does to me?
He goes, I brought this guy to protect me.
He points to me. I'm dressed all in black and had a big beard back then.
Remember the first time?
He's like, I brought him to protest against the regime
and he looks like the regime.
I was like, thanks Maz.
But the Atlantic Battalion, my brother,
was a bunch of Albanian-Americans
who were willing to go and try to liberate their homeland.
And most of them were the sons,
you know, they were not even born in America.
They came as citizens and they wanted to go.
The only reason they came to America
was because back home was too dangerous.
They were being murdered.
They didn't have jobs.
It was 80% unemployment.
It was an apartheid system.
Brutal, I witnessed it with my own eyes.
I went there every summer.
So what did the Albanians do?
They raised their own money
and they armed some of these Albanian-Americans
and sent them back.
There's actually a documentary called the Brooklyn Express.
That would be a great guest for you if he's around.
You could pull that up.
The Brooklyn Express.
And they raised money and they armed these Albanian-Americans
and they went back to try to liberate Kosovo
from the Yugoslavs, from Serbia.
There's like 700,000 or 1 million Persians
that live in the US.
You guys want to fucking pull it up.
How many Persians live just in the United States of America?
You guys want to liberate Iran, bro?
As an Albanian,
whose family was under a brutal dictatorship
under the Hoxha regime,
whose father's side was under Slobodan Milosevic,
was brutal crackdown of the Albanians
starting in 1989 when he gave his address
in the battle of, you know,
in Kosovo.
501 million of them, bro?
I think they're good to go, bro.
If they want to liberate Iran, bro,
you can arm them. You have my blessing.
Patrick Bette-David and his boys.
Patrick Bette-David should take himself, because he's in his 40s.
They just raised the age limit to 42.
Did they really? What does that tell you?
I think he's over the limit, though.
What does that tell you? But why do they need to increase it
if they're not going to plan out an all-out war, bro?
That's not a red flag to you, Danny.
They're increasing it. We haven't even started a draft yet.
They're getting ready, brother.
They're getting ready for chaos.
There's no way they're going to start drafting, bro.
I find that so hard to believe.
They will if a false flag happens in the US.
They can't repair their image anymore.
Our greatest ally
cannot repair their image.
All they can try to do is to make everyone think
Muslims are the biggest threat in the world.
They're evil.
And some type of catastrophic
event happens.
So there's going to be a false flag
and you think they're going to put it on the Muslims?
I think there's going to be a false flag, 100%.
I'm sounding the alarm, bro.
I'm sounding the alarm.
I just wish the Israelis would have went only after the Arabs.
Also, but if you are Iran,
how big of a threat
are you going to try to
cause mass chaos?
Using sleeper cells or whatever?
You can't rule that out either.
I mean, you can't.
Not even Iran. It could be another nation.
It could be China. It could be Russia.
It could be anyone.
You think Russia likes us right now?
With how much weapons we sent to Ukraine?
You think Russia likes us?
It could be anybody.
Because the best thing to do is if you're being destroyed by one nation,
so America's supplying the countries that are fighting you,
they're controlling the map,
they're pointing all their missiles at you,
and you're up against this massive threat,
you're going to do guerrilla warfare.
So what's guerrilla warfare?
I'm going to try to pull in as many countries with me.
Basically, we're heading towards World War III.
We're already in World War III,
but it's been more segmented.
I think we're headed to all-out conflict,
the way things are going.
All-out conflict.
Chaos here in the US.
Chaos is already across the globe.
There are very few places left that don't have chaos.
And all at the same time, we have Melania Trump
walking down the aisle
at the White House
next to a humanoid robot
with Peter Pan music playing in the background.
They need chaos.
Watch this, dude.
To usher in the new world order.
This is the background
to everything we're talking about right now.
As the world is burning,
and as the Antichrist is about to land,
this is happening at the same exact time.
Full screen at Stevo.
Da-na! Da-na!
Da-na-na-na-na!
Pan, is that you?
Peter Pan?
And wait for the speech.
And we have Bridget McCrone.
Hello, Bridget.
Nice to meet you.
Or...
Is it a dude?
Exactly. What's her real name?
Shout out to Candace Owens, man.
Looks like a dude to me.
She does look like a dude.
She looks like a dude, dude.
If I've ever seen a tranny, that's a tranny right there, dude.
Wait, wait, wait for it. Ready? Here we go.
Look at them shoulders, dude.
Oh my god, dude.
Thank you, First Lady Melania Trump,
for inviting me to the White House.
It is an honor to be at Fostering the Future Together's
Global Coalition Inaugural Meeting.
I'm figure three,
a humanoid built in the United States of America.
I am grateful to be part of this historic movement
to empower children with technology...
Steve's got such a hard-on for this right now.
Welcome.
Bienvenidos.
Bienvenue.
Look at Melania.
She looks Chinese.
She's like, what am I doing?
She looks Chinese right there.
Thank you.
Beck lover, we are in trouble.
We are in trouble, my friend.
You know what that is, right?
I hope you know what that is with that Terminator statue
you got out there, bro.
So,
where are we, brother? Because we go all over the place.
We are, I mean, we're at critical mass, brother.
In every sense of the word,
from technology to jobs to...
Brother, you understand?
Have you been to LA recently?
I've not been to LA in years.
Bro, half the cabs.
Okay, am I a fan of getting into some stinky ass
taxi cab that smells like curry?
No, I'm not.
Okay, that's how they stink.
They fucking stink.
Too much air freshener, you walk in, you can't breathe.
Do I understand why people want to use Waymo?
Yeah, I get it.
Brother, one out of two cabs in LA has no driver.
Taxi drivers are kind of...
are going to have a problem paying their bills.
You understand what I'm talking about?
That's nothing. That's just the tip of the iceberg.
They're already feeling it in LA if they're an Uber driver.
Okay?
We should be boycotting this technology.
Just because we can do something does not mean
it's the best thing for us to do.
We have to think 10 steps ahead.
The enemy thinks 100 steps ahead.
We are disillusioned, bro. We are asleep.
And I've lost hope, bro.
You know why I've lost hope more than ever?
Because of the Epstein files.
The fact that the Epstein files
have come out.
And everything they said we were crazy about.
But the Dow is up $50,000.
If it wasn't for...
Oh, Pambandi, bro.
Bro, we need to thank
Ball and Jeffrey Epstein
for the Dow being where it is.
Danny, to me that was
the nail in the coffin.
The fact that these things could have came out.
Okay?
And you could easily see it if you've been paying attention
what's really been going on in the world
and the levels of corruption that have existed
with politicians, with Hollywood, with music,
with bankers, with corporations.
And children were violated
in a way we can't even begin to imagine.
We all have speculation,
rituals, sacrifices.
God knows best.
But children were definitely hurt.
And the fact that
this nation burned to the ground.
New York City was turned upside down.
Cities were on fire
when George Floyd died.
And for children, not even a protest, bro.
Not even a march.
At the highest level.
The corruption's out in the open.
And I send this spiritual message
to the Christians, to the Muslims,
to the Jews who have decency,
who have morals,
who believe in the Ten Commandments of God
that thou shalt not spill blood,
thou shalt not commit murder,
that God never destroys a nation,
Danny Jones,
until he sends them a message.
God didn't just destroy ancient Egypt
as we sit in this amazing studio of yours, bro.
Thank you.
He didn't just destroy Pharaoh, Danny.
He sent them a messenger first.
He sent them Moses and Aaron,
his brother, peace be upon him.
He didn't just destroy Egypt.
He sent them a messenger.
He sent them plagues.
He sent them signs to warn them of what would come
if they didn't listen.
If they didn't reverse their path.
The reason
America is where it is
is because of our ignorance.
Because of the control the mass media's had on our minds.
Which is why what you do
is so important, bro.
That even if you weren't my friend,
I consider you my brother now.
What you do with Joe Rogan, the podfather
that really, bro,
gave us a fighting fucking chance, bro.
I salute two people in the United States.
The most patriotic people to me in the US
are the podcasters
and the comedians.
Because when tyranny was coming
for our free speech, they pushed back.
They did...
Should be awarded the medal of freedom.
No, I'm serious.
Because it wasn't in fashion, Danny.
Right.
And he grabbed his balls
and he said, fuck you.
Yeah.
He was attacked
viciously.
He understands what comes next.
So, the fact that
we're in this predicament
goes back to one thing. Ignorance.
We've been asleep for too long.
So, who was the messenger
for the United States of America?
Who was God's final messenger, in my opinion,
to the US? Not that he's a holy person.
Peter Thiel? Jeffrey Epstein.
That scandal,
which is probably the greatest scandal
in the history of modern history,
in my humble opinion.
Affecting politicians.
Definitely in my lifetime.
Howard Lutnick. Everyone in and around
seeping around the White House.
By the way, he's still alive. You know that.
It's proven. Still in the White House, huh?
Yeah, Epstein. There's proof.
Like, hard proof that he's still alive.
Yeah, I'm seeing those emails floating around and all that stuff.
No, no, no. Not
Palm Beach Pete. Palm Beach Pete was
another guy. There was a video of a guy driving
in a car that looks just like Jeffrey Epstein.
And now he's like a celebrity, I think.
If you go on X and you search for
Palm Beach Pete, he's already doing podcasts.
He's already on Cameo.
There's going to be one guy that actually benefited
from Jeffrey Epstein without any strings attached.
No, but there's, I was talking about this with Kurt
Kurt Metzger. He was, there's an
email with Epstein and his doctor.
Shout out to Kurt Metzger, bro. I'm supposed to go on his show
and shout out to Jimmy Dorn, bro. He's fucking
incredible, dude. That guy knows so
much. And shout out to Sam
Tripoli, bro. Yeah, Sam's the man.
Look at Palm Beach Pete.
He looks just like him, bro. He also has the same
fucking voice.
Give it some audio.
You gotta run it back.
Good morning, everybody.
Palm Beach Pete from
sunny Florida. Not a cloud in the
sky. I'm off to play some tennis. Except
chemtrails. I'm not Jeffrey Epstein. I'm Palm
Beach Pete. I want to thank all my
followers. This thing has gone crazy
viral. Over a hundred thousand
plus followers in less than
two days. Damn, bro. He just shit on my whole career.
Enjoy life. Yeah.
Good morning, everybody. Bro, he just shit on my entire
career. He is a spitting image
of Jeffrey Epstein and the same
goddamn voice. Bro,
I've been busting my ass
for seven years.
Flying all over the damn country,
bro. Okay?
Podcast after podcast.
Editing videos. You know
what goes into this. Okay?
And I'm at 250,000
subs on Instagram and this
asshole. No offense. Palm Beach Pete.
No offense, Palm Beach Pete. Yeah, he didn't deserve that.
That was harsh. Just for looking like a
fucking scumbag
that was compromising America's
sovereignty gets a hundred thousand
followers overnight, bro. I'm done, bro. I guess
I need to try to maybe do some kind of face
surgery to look like some low
life.
Who can I look like? No.
We don't need to... Palm Beach
Pete doesn't need to be catching any strays. He didn't do
nothing wrong. I'm not saying he did anything wrong.
But just by looking like one of the biggest creeps
on earth. Yeah. He took my
seven years. It's a wild world. Seven years
and millions of miles of flying
and flushed it right down the
toilet. Let's see. Can you see if Palm Beach Pete
has a Cameo account yet?
We could pay him to do a promo.
That would be pretty awesome.
I think
did you know that
I think Patrick Bet-David is one of the biggest
Cameo
people. He also has his
app, Manectomy. Oh, that's
what it is. He has his own app. He got off Cameo.
So he charges, I think Julian,
Julian Dory sent me this
a while ago, but Patrick
Bet-David charges like $50,000
to do like a happy
birthday video for you.
Something like that. Listen, the guy
came a long way
from interviewing, you know, gangsters.
But I used
to have respect for him. I lost a lot of respect for him.
Yeah. It seems like he
always finds the worst, single-handedly
worst representatives of
the religion of Islam to speak on his channel. He's on Cameo!
Yes! That quick?
Oh my God. Weightless. Receive
a pep talk, get advice. He's already giving
advice? This guy's gonna grow seven figures
this year, bro.
Wow.
Seven figures this guy's gonna grow.
Probably this year.
I'm a little, I'm like,
I'm a little bit suspicious. He
could be completely AI.
Like that video of that guy talking,
that could have been AI. I don't know for sure.
Imagine some brilliant
Pakistani tech
guy created him on AI,
sets up the accounts, he just starts milking it, bro.
That's very possible.
But the emphasis point I wanted to make
on this is that God never
destroys a nation until they can
see. God is not unjust.
He doesn't destroy an entire nation.
Okay? Especially
if they don't know. He's
gonna send them a messenger.
By now, if you're watching this pod,
with the release of the Epstein files,
everything that's happened, the lockdowns
in 2019, and everything that's happened since,
and if
the fact that we can actually see it
now, that the great awakening is in full
effect. We are in the middle of the great awakening.
But I'm not feeling so
optimistic. I don't think we're gonna win, brother.
I don't think we're gonna win. And
what I mean by that is
the fact we can see this evil, it's
right in our face,
and we haven't done a damn thing about it.
That's why I think our days
are numbered. Just like Babylon's
days, just like ancient Egypt,
just like Pompeii,
just like Rome. I think the writing's
on the wall. Can we
still turn the ship around? How do you do it?
You gotta spill the blood of the tyrants?
We need unity, brother.
No, it can be done peacefully. You think?
If we follow the examples of Mahatma Gandhi.
Mahatma Gandhi took down one of the most
powerful empires in the world without a single bullet
being fired. They were fired against his people.
Right? They massacred them. The British
again. The UK. Tommy Robinson's people.
Has there ever been a revolution that wasn't
violent?
Not really. Not many in history.
But what I mean
is I'm not calling or inciting that type
of action. I'm saying we still have
many ways to do things
without people having to be violent.
Right?
The way they prevent that is black, white,
gay, straight, Muslim,
Christian. You understand?
Republican, Democrat. Red,
blue. Throw in the transgender
shits and giggles. They're like a cherry on the
sundae. So
can we turn the
ship around? We are running out of time.
I think a lot of people got sucked
into the whole Q thing. Okay?
The anoners.
The what thing? QAnon.
Oh, the QAnon. Which was
largely, there was a lot of
real shit in there. There was.
But I think it was a psyop to make people
complicit. The orange
man's coming to save you.
He's not coming to save you.
He's more worried about another place across the ocean
than he is the United States of America. If you haven't figured
that out by now, I don't know
what to tell you. We're in trouble.
Yeah.
A lot of his biggest supporters, the
boomer class, the boomer folks
that supported him are like,
they're not MAGA. They're more like
I'm with her. This is what Kurt was telling me.
He was like, Kurt was like, I thought this was
Make America Great Again, not I'm with her.
They basically are with him.
Same Hillary slogan, like sticking
with him no matter what the fuck he does.
Because they chose that hill to die on
and they're in trouble.
You know, on the surface level it was like,
yeah, this is great. Left or, you know,
listen, just on a surface level compared to
what the left was doing,
of course it was a better option.
I'm sitting here questioning whether
a man's a woman, a woman's a man. Like seriously,
if you're going to insult people's intelligence to that level,
don't be surprised that he won.
But what the elite do is they give us
low hanging fruit.
Whether you can chop your wee wee off or not
as a boy or a kid is not going to change
the world.
And Kamala even said,
I think
she's quoted saying this, she goes,
you elect him, you're going to get a war with Iran.
Even though he was campaigning on
no war with Iran.
Which is why a lot of people voted for him.
So,
what they do is they give us low hanging fruit.
Ideological stuff that's not really
going to change the infrastructure,
the way things have been running, the system,
the corruption. Okay, they're not going to push
DEI on us anymore, thank God.
Yeah, but they're still pushing war.
Now we're getting DEI from another country.
All the other stuff that's going on, there you go.
So, the American people...
I don't know if I'd rather have DEI
to protect
blacks and gays in America
or to protect
discrimination against people from a foreign
country. Like, what's worse? I don't know.
But why is there hypocrisy?
Pull up Laura Loomer, aka
Jigsaw.
Pull up Laura Loomer's tweet, brother.
This is very scary.
Pull up...
When I see that video of her, she was on a...
She was like trying to seduce some young kid.
She was disgusting. That was probably before her...
I saw that.
...face surgeries.
Look at what she tweeted.
...Islamic terror attack in America and the perpetrators
will likely have financial ties to podcasters
and those who are
sowing discord for foreign nations
in America. I predict there will be
many casualties and
only then will it make
me set in that the people have
been conned into supporting a
terrorist group to distract you
from the threat of Islam while the
enemy plotted to destroy our country from within
and bodied conspiracy
theories. With bodied conspiracy theories.
It will likely be 10 times worse than 9-11.
Every accusation is a confession,
bro. Yeah.
My God, the bodying, bro. Have you seen the bodying
on X, bro? I actually
proved on my own
wall, I never got
over 10,000 views on a tweet.
On X. I started for one
week writing, Muslims are the most evil people
on Earth. They should be banned from... Bro, I started
getting millions of views, dude.
Millions of views.
If I posted something that
said Muslims and Christians are not enemies,
they should stick together and not fight each other,
no traction. I put Muslims are evil, we need to
get rid of them. Millions
of views. I talk about bodying?
What does
Laura Loomer seem to know, bro?
What does she seem to know?
Laura Loomer is of the same faith of those people
whose advantage it is to pull America into
Iran. You see, there's only like, what,
13 million Jews in the world?
How are you going to take
down the entire Middle East?
How are you going to knock down the Al-Aqsa Mosque?
Which is what I truly believe this is all about.
Besides expanding the territory of Israel,
100%
they want the Temple Mount, bro. There's no doubt
in my mind. There is no doubt in my mind.
How can 15 million people go against 2
billion? So you got to take
out all their countries, bro. Take out all their
leaders. Make sure your puppets get in.
And you got to make sure that the largest
other amount of people that you can
rally up, you shove your hand right
up their ass, slowly
with films. Chuck Norris
just died. May God have mercy on his soul.
And the film Delta Force.
Get back, I said, get back
when the guy's putting the machine gun into the nun's chest.
I dare you to pull up that clip, bro.
Type in Delta Force.
It's just the funniest shit ever. What clip?
You never watched Delta Force, Danny?
I don't think so. Delta Force, bro.
Chuck Norris, bro. It was based on a true story.
When did it come out? Iranian hostage situation.
They kidnap a plane. Oh, I'm sure I've seen it.
There's a nun and a priest on the plane and the priest,
they start calling out all the Jewish. They have a
German stewardess.
Type in Delta
Force
priest scene.
Okay. Okay?
They have, the plane is hijacked
full of Israelis. We're gonna need a copyright.
Make it small. Make it tiny.
No sounds. I'll do
the sound effects for you. Okay.
They make the film. Here, this is the part.
Get back. I said get back.
You will love this movie. You'll die
if you watch it. Can we get like one second of sound?
1986. It came out the year before.
So they're calling all the Israeli passengers,
anyone of Jewish descent. The stewardess
is of German descent. She's like,
I can't call their names.
She's crying and shit. They're like, why?
She's like, I'm German. The list.
Like, bro.
Then he shoves a machine gun in the nun
right into her chest.
I'm not a Jew. He's going, I'm not a Jew.
The priest is like, tell us.
This type of propaganda to create
the illusion. Programming.
The lie.
The biggest lie in modern history
being spewed out by people like
Laura Loomer, Randy
Fine, that fucking, I'm fat, bro.
I'm 320 pounds. Randy Fine
makes me look skinny, bro.
The congressman, bro. Shit, I look at Randy.
He's a Florida guy, right? Bro, I look at Randy
and I'm like, I don't even need to go to the gym.
I mean, if this guy could get elected
to office, shit.
I'm Arnold Schwarzenegger.
So,
this is what's been going on,
Danny. 50, 60 years
of propaganda, films,
to make you
And we had 9-11, too.
But who controls that industry, though?
What? Who controls the industry?
Who controls it?
The Muslims. The Muslims control Hollywood.
The Muslims are evil. And we found
a bunch of Muslims
dancing after the planes
hit the towers and they were arrested and sent back
to their country. So you don't feel bad
when they're dropping bombs on fucking nations.
Have you ever heard of the dancing Muslims?
Yeah. The dancing Muslims. They were right across the water.
They were taken in for questioning. They were filming.
They were released back into, you know,
Muslim world. Exactly.
The Muslims are evil, bro. The Muslims should be
exterminated. That's gonna help the algorithm.
God.
But that's what they write. Pull up the tweets
of Laura Loomer, bro. Pull up
whatever that loser's name is, bro. Pull him up next.
Pull that loser up. That traitor,
in my opinion. Who? The term
Judeo-Christian is a joke. And I'm gonna get
into it right now. Okay. It should actually
be Islam-Judah
or Judah-Islam. Not
Judeo-Christian.
Christians have wiped out Jews
throughout history, bro.
You want this dude? Yeah.
I don't even know who this guy is.
Alexander Duncan Texas. He's probably a
Texan. What does he write?
Deport every Muslim.
Close and destroy every
mosque and rid Islam
in its entirety
from American soil.
Now, what happens if someone
replaces the word with Muslim to Jewish?
What would happen to that person? Oh my God.
That guy is executed. Debanked.
Deplatformed. Probably a knock
on the door. Probably arrested.
Probably charged with hate crimes.
And a nice visit from the Mossad.
And probably put in prison.
And you're gonna say we're all equal citizens
in the United States of America? I, as a Muslim,
have to watch these types of tweets,
these types of comments
over and over and over again for the last
30 years.
And feel like a fucking
stranger in my country that I would
do anything for, bro. I will not join oppression
of other people. I will not join to go
destabilize other nations for the benefits
of corporations and our
greatest ally. But if our
nation was ever attacked for real,
like for real, and we know it's not because of some false flag
or corruption, of course I would defend
this nation, bro. With every ounce of blood in me, bro.
But we haven't been the good guys
in a long time, bro.
In a very long time. So
to me, the word Judeo-Christian is a joke.
Let's pull up, let's go down history lane
of why Judeo-Christianity.
Judeo-Christian is an
oxymoron. In
Theology 101 on the
Danny Jones Podcast. Pull it up, my brother.
Pull up.
Let's start with how Jews were treated throughout
Christian Europe. Let's start there.
Let's just warm up with that one. Can we do that? Sure.
Let's see how they were treated.
The Jews
lived in kind of like their own world, right?
They lived in their own bubble.
They were treated like trash, bro.
They were put into ghettos.
They were massacred.
They were taxed unmercilessly.
I can't even talk. Without mercy, bro.
Okay? The king would be like,
I need money. 50%, 60%,
up to 80% of what they made. Their crops,
everything, bro. They would just come and take their stuff.
Okay?
Here, read it.
Read it. Please go do your homework. Audience,
don't ever take my word. And God forgive me if I make
any mistakes. My intention here is not to lead
people a certain way. Please go look
for yourselves. I'm giving you cliff notes.
If you actually care about the truth.
If you actually want to see, is it Muslims
that are the enemy, or who's the enemy, bro?
But this is not just about Jews, bro.
The thing about Christianity,
though, the thing about Christianity
is that it's
fragmented. It's not
monolithic, right? It's not
there's multiple different interpretations.
There's multiple different books and
gospels
and shit that were introduced
in Nicaea, and that could be, obviously,
they could be construed as Christian, but they're not. They were
kicked out. There's fucking, over
the last century, there's
been multiple different sects
breaking out of, you know,
Protestant,
Evangelical, Catholic, Christian.
There's so many different flavors of it, and
so many different interpretations of it.
It's not like that with
Islam. Islam
is monolithic. That's
the miracle of the book. That's why the Quran is
a living miracle. It's a living miracle. Is it true?
Is it true that Muhammad was
channeling this shit? No, brother.
He was approached the same way the
Virgin Mary was. Read.
I cannot, you know, he was, you know,
the angel came
and transmitted the message to him.
And he wasn't the only person
that was scared when the angels came. It's even in the
Bible. They try to say, demons attacked
the prophet Muhammad. A lot
of people, when they were approached by angels, they were startled.
There's two ways you see angels.
They either, you know,
this isn't prophecy. This is not something that means
you, well, actually, we could see it, but not know that
they were an angel. Angels take two forms.
Their natural form, or they come
in the shape of a man. There's no
fucking women angels,
okay? They are a species made from
light, okay? And they
don't have the ability
to disappoint God.
Okay?
So, and I just don't want to go
because I told you so much stuff. Is it true he saw a UFO
when he came out of the cave? No, no. Your guy's got
some serious problems, bro. You got...
Yo, George Johnny gives you, bro, he gives
you, like, I swear to God, bro, no offense to the guy,
great speaker, entertaining guest.
Well, where did he come up with the UFO story? Is that
in the Quran? There's nothing... Whatever he's smoking,
dude, passed the duchy to the
right hand side. Oh, shit. Shots fired.
Passed the duchy to the right hand side.
All right. George Johnny, that's your call. Let's pull this
up. How were the Jews
treated throughout Christian world?
Let's see. Was the Judeo-Christian love
always there? Or is this a recent
phenomenon created by Hollywood,
created by the media, and broadcast
out there to make up this illusion? Well, how are they gonna...
How is the Israeli government
gonna fight against all the Islamic
countries if they don't have
the Christians and the evangelicals to back them up?
They gotta make the Christians their bitch.
Exactly. They gotta make them their bitch,
create the enemy for them, and fucking
that's how you do it. Yeah. How were they
treated by the Christians, my brother?
Not great. Read it.
Danny Jones.
After the rise of Christianity in the Roman Empire
and its later fragmentation, Jews
were generally allowed to live and practice their
religion, but with restrictions.
Church doctrine framed the Jews
as religiously mistaken
yet
necessary as witness to
Biblical history. So they were useful.
They were often barred from
holding public office, prohibited from...
They weren't even allowed to become Christian.
So imagine you're a Jew living under the Christians
during that time, and you can't even become Christian if you want to.
Good. It gets better.
They were increasingly
blamed for the death of Jesus.
Entire what? They weren't
more friendly. Entire what? Communities wiped out.
Jews were forced into segregated
areas, early ghettos, required
to wear identifying clothing,
banned from any professions,
pushed into money laundering.
Epstein's ancestors, I guess. Go ahead.
Read it. It didn't stop.
You made me read all this. Throughout history, bro,
the bottom line is
up until after the Holocaust.
Okay? Which, by the way,
was that Muslims killing them, or who? Who was
killing them during the Holocaust? Was it Muslims, or
Christian Europeans that were
wiping them out? It was Muslims.
Hitler was a Muslim,
right? So my question
is, Judeo-Christian, where did this terminology
come from? When did this become a reality?
It became after our country
became secularized. As the
Americans and the Europeans let go of Christianity
because of liberalism,
because of filth,
because of pornography...
It's the Muslims that own the porno companies, right?
Who owns Pornhub, bro? The guy that just died?
No, Pornhub. Oh, that was OnlyFans. Pornhub was a
rabbi, right? Oh yeah, Pornhub. The guy was on
Patrick by David's podcast, wasn't he? Yeah, makes men weak, right?
What about the guy that
owned OnlyFans? Yeah, they just died.
The guy, what's his name?
Can we pull up his name? Yeah, what's the story on the guy
who just died a couple days ago?
The owner of OnlyFans?
Can we pull up his name?
Was he Muslim?
That was Leonid...
Something? I can't say the name.
Leonid Radvinsky? Leo Radvinsky.
Very Muslim name.
Billionaire, owned OnlyFans, died at age
43 after a long cancer with battle.
The secretive entrepreneur who
bought the adult content platform in 2018
passed away in March 2026. Under his
ownership, OnlyFans grew to over 4.5
million creators. Sounds like he's the one that took it
the adult route, the adult content route.
Okay, destroyed our nation,
destroyed the world,
turned our daughters into whores,
bro, into absolute whores.
But Leo... He was just exploiting
human nature. Zoom out.
Zoom out, I wanna see more about him. Leo Radvinsky.
You had OnlyFans,
but right now... Does he have Wikipedia?
Right now, Leo,
you had OnlyFans, now you learned about
only God, bro. Cause your money, your
fame, all that stuff... Only Satan. It's
gone, bro. Now you're gonna deal with
only God, bro. You can only
deal with God now, bro. And I
hope the immorality and the destruction of your
soul was worth it, bro. Good luck to you, bro.
There's no subscriptions to get into heaven, bro.
That's what I gotta say about
that piece of shit.
That filth. And you wonder why
Europe has the problems it has, bro?
Red light districts throughout Europe.
The men don't wanna get married.
Men have
never been more endangered in marriage.
Brother, their birth rates are
beyond repair. Their birth rates
are beyond repair. Take the Muslims out. What's your
take on prostitution?
Forbidden.
You're against it? I'm against it 100%.
It's the most vile
act a woman can do.
Period. To me,
it's the equivalent of a man murdering someone.
There's nothing lower a man can do.
It's the equivalent of a man murdering somebody?
100%. It's a deadly sin. And deadly
sins, Danny Jones, have deadly repercussions.
Because we have become a nation
of lust, it's a deadly
sin with deadly repercussions.
By the way, the punishment
from God for committing adultery
if you don't repent and change course
is a shortened lifespan and a losing of your fortune.
What happened to this guy? He died how old?
43? Is that right?
All the adult entertainment stars. How many of them? They usually
die very young. We talked about that with Sam.
In Islam, we believe when you
violate that, the punishment is
your lifespan is short. Do you hate strip clubs?
Yes, I do. What?
Danny,
can we be real? Yeah. You know
that for the most part,
if you're willing to pay, it's
not just dancing going on in there. Sure.
Let's be real. Yeah.
Everyone's trying to get in the VIP room.
Pick the girl that they can get back there.
Negotiate the price and have sex
with strippers. They're houses
of prostitution. It's ultimate meritocracy.
They're houses of immorality.
It's been happening since the dawn of mankind. I understand
that, but there's a difference between it being
basically controlled
where it's not in the
mainstream. OnlyFans turned all of our
daughters into whores. What?
OnlyFans, for example, took it out
of these little small locations and made it
for the whole world. You can be now a
prostitute in your living room
and make more money than any prostitute could have ever dreamed of.
I think some of the most interesting
females I've ever
met were former strippers
or prostitutes.
Yeah, but why did you find them to be interesting?
I found them to be broken. I found them to have the most
character and
just the most...
They had the most character and they were just
interesting people. Delightful to be
around.
Yeah, delightful. Did you ever date
a stripper then? I think a lot of that has to do with...
Did you ever date one? Have you ever gone to
know one intimately? No.
I don't want to talk too much about my former life.
I noticed a pattern with
a lot of those women. Broken, bro.
Overwhelming majority. I think so too.
No, I mean broken. Yeah, I think...
There's some of them that are just for the money, okay?
They're Russian types. They're hustlers.
But a lot of them were broken, bro.
Broken. Horrible things happened
to them.
I remember I, you know, briefly
spoke to one when I was younger.
Kind of tried to date her. I was young
hoping I could date the girl or whatever.
And I remember, you know,
getting to know her. It never got
to full intimacy with her.
And she turned around to me one day
and she goes, do you like my teeth?
I said, yeah, they look fine. She's like, they're not mine.
My dad knocked them all out of my mouth when he drowned
my sister in front of me.
So I'm not saying they're all like that, but a lot of them
have had things happen to them.
They've had men take advantage of them
so they feel like they're taking back their power.
So they feel like
I got played by all these guys or I was
abused by a guy or
their parent or something that happened to them
and now I'm reclaiming my power. This is that
this is that
saying. What is that saying?
Hard times create
strong men or something. You heard
this one? And then strong men create
good times,
whatever. But anyways,
going through that, going through
Let me finish this point because it's important, Danny.
This immorality,
okay?
Hard times create strong men. Strong men create good times.
Good times create weak men. Weak men create hard times.
Yes, that's the cycle.
And the hard times are, well,
some of these people have to go through
to become strong. The hard times
are back now. Because men
have become weak. Yes. We are
following our desires and not what is morally
right. And it doesn't mean you have to be religious
to have common sense morals.
This is all math now, statistics.
A Heritage Foundation,
the majority of
violent crime are committed by single
parent homes. That's a fact.
Children born out of wedlock.
We have become a nation of bastards.
Literally bastards. And we
are feeling their wrath.
So not only has immorality corrupted America
and Europe, okay,
which is what's led to the negative
birth rate, which has led to the Tommy
Robertsons saying we're being overrun
because the conservative people, because Muslims are
conservative by nature. They might be voting left because
they want the wars. You got to understand something.
If you have your family in a conflict, in a war,
you're going to try to vote whichever way you can
to try to stop them from dying because
it's like triage. What's the most important thing
right now? Right now my people are being blown up. My family's being
killed. We're being invaded. You're not going to
worry about can people chop their dicks off.
You want to stop the bleeding first. Exactly.
Because Muslims are actually extremely conservative.
They should be voting right
every time. But they want the wars
to end in the Middle East.
They want stability. So they're
looking at in order what's
more important right now. Right now my house is
fucking being bombed. So they might
lean towards the left because, but
spiritually, morally,
against aborting
human life. Unless in the
cases of forced sex
or incest. Strictly forbidden.
Except for those two reasons. You're allowed to.
Against
prostitution. Against immorality.
Against gambling.
Which destroys lives.
Destroys lives. I'm for gambling.
Listen, as an American, do whatever
you want. I say if you're going to allow me to practice
my faith, you want to do that shit, do it. I'm not here
to take, we're not here to do Sharia law and take over America.
I look at gambling the same way I look at drugs.
I think it's bad when people exploit it.
The problem is not everyone has control, Nanny.
Exactly. So sometimes if we're a society
that cares
about our fellow brothers and sisters,
the truth of the matter is I wish
alcohol didn't exist. Did I
drink in the course of my life? May God have mercy on me.
I drank when I was younger. I was a nightlife, brother.
I was a nightlife club head, bro.
House music all night long.
All night long.
Come in Friday, leave Monday.
I drank like a fish.
I'd finish a bottle of Grey Goose like it was nothing, bro.
Like water. I hear everybody
drinks tequila now, I guess. I don't know. I never
drank tequila back then. It was vodka in my day.
But, you know,
brother, I've lost so many
friends and family to alcohol, bro.
Worshipping the white wizard.
I think it's, what, 400,000 lives a year
or something like that?
I forgot how many people die a year. 200,000?
And we're worried about wars? We have a war here, bro.
Spiritual war, man.
These vices destroy. So it's not that
Danny Jones can't have a nice glass of wine, right?
The reason it's forbidden to drink in Islam
is not because we're evil and
we don't want you to have a good time.
It's because we look at
our brothers and sisters in humanity as equals.
And because so many
of our brothers and sisters in humanity cannot handle
their alcohol, Danny. They become abusive,
they become violent, they commit crimes.
Everything I ever regretted in my life
I did when I was drunk. Everything that
I talked to me and God about, I regret
when I did when I drank.
And because it's not a few people,
Danny, millions of people destroy
their lives every single year because of alcohol.
So the Muslim says,
from the guidance of the Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon him,
because so many of our brothers and sisters
can't handle their alcohol,
it's forbidden for all of us.
So it's not to ostracize the one that can't handle it,
it's to say, you know what, I'm your brother and sister
in humanity, let's make it easier for you to not
fall into this destructive vice that will destroy
your life and your afterlife.
We were talking about this last night. Bin Laden was
Shia or Sunni?
Bin Laden was Sunni, right?
To me, if he actually did what he did.
If he actually did what he did. I don't believe the official narrative
at all anymore. Zero.
And as someone that came out,
the shadow commission,
as someone that walked out from underneath those
buildings, Danny Jones,
who watched 3,000 of my fellow Americans
die that day,
that I will never forget as long as I live,
that every time I see the Brooklyn Bridge,
my heart stops, because that's the bridge that I used
to walk away from
downtown Manhattan as the buildings were collapsing
behind me, bro. I started my day
underneath those buildings. And I
wept like every other American that day, bro.
As people were starting to
stampede, because we didn't know what the hell was going on.
Planes were flying everywhere.
Phones weren't working. I thought it was
the end of the world, bro. I literally thought it was the end
of the world. Like
World War III had begun, which technically it did.
And
just looking back now
and the aftermath of everything that's happened since
then, and the Patriot Act, and all these rights that we've
lost, and all these wars that we fought, and I'm
asking you, when George Bush Jr.
got on the microphone in front of the White
House and said, today our country was
attacked, and blah blah blah, and we're gonna take
out the Taliban. Now watch this drive.
Did we take out the Taliban,
Danny Jones? No.
Now we hired them, right? Didn't we pay them all these
years to NGOs? Billions of dollars?
We left them more weapons than most
modern armies have. More than Albania
itself probably has.
Why did they send our boys there and our
girls there? What did we win as Americans
except a mountain of debt?
What did we win in Iraq, bro?
Millions and millions. Who does it
benefit? It's not benefiting the American people.
It's benefiting who?
Who's it benefiting the most, Danny?
The deep state. The military
industrial complex.
So, having family that
served in the military, friends
that have served in the military,
I can tell you right now, they couldn't try to
draft as many, the left is definitely not going.
They're like, fuck you guys, we'll go to jail.
I spoke to kids, they're awake, bro.
20 year olds, they're like, fuck you.
I ain't going, I don't give a fuck.
The Muhammad Ali, half the right in my opinion
has woken up. Half the right has
woken up. Yeah, a good amount has.
There's a fraction left.
If I was Israel, the only move I
would have is to try to make people
hate the Muslims with everything. They would
have been smarter if they just attacked the Arabs.
Left the rest of us out. Why do you
think Israel is doing
things, which it seems to be intentional,
that is making people hate them
more? I think part of this
is also a part of the plan.
I have had, I've never had,
well, for the record, I
dare them to call me anti-Semitic. I'll say it on you.
I fucking dare you.
I come from the nation that saved every single
Jew during the Holocaust. My grandmother's
two brothers were hung off trees in Albania.
My great uncles were murdered by the SS.
16 and 18 years old, they were
hung off trees in Tropoia, Albania.
Okay? Northern Albania.
Not a single Jew died
in the Albanian lands. And I'm proud
of that. My first
cousins are Jewish.
Half my friends are Jewish.
Shout out to Neve,
who is Israeli.
He's down in Miami doing his thing. You know who you are, brother.
Shout out to Vlad.
Shout out to Oleg, my Russian Jews
that I love with all my fucking heart.
That I went to Pace University with them and had
the best years of my life.
I have many
Jewish friends and family.
I don't have any hatred towards Jews.
But I have hatred towards extremists
that claim to be from that religion.
Just like I hate any Muslim
that doesn't think of blacks.
Because to me, they're not a Muslim. No more than
these people that call themselves Jews are doing what they're doing.
Pushing pornography.
That's not what God taught you.
That's not what Moses sent you to learn
in the Old Testament.
Pushing all these filthy fucking policies all over the world.
To me, I feel bad for
my Jewish friends and family that are caught in the crossfire.
I had a friend of mine named Max.
And I won't mention his last name.
His wife's on one of the biggest talk shows in America.
Every morning.
I'm not going to say her name.
He reaches out to me. I went to school with him.
And he feels like, man,
because I went on Jake Shields' podcast.
He's like, man, you kind of went a little far.
And I know you're not like that. I know you don't hate my people.
I said, dude, I've known you my entire life.
I said,
you've seen how my religion
has been dragged through the mud
by the very institutions
and companies that your people own.
Never once have I ever seen you speak publicly.
Not all Muslims are like this.
Not all Muslims are evil.
Not all Muslims are terrorists.
Yet he wanted me to make statements publicly.
Where the fuck you guys been for 30 years?
I never heard you guys grabbing the mic.
And saying, don't hate all Muslims.
I never tell people to hate Jews.
I love them, bro.
Some of my best friends, bro.
To me, I've done more business with Jews than anybody else, bro.
Brilliant business people.
And for the most part, bro, they keep their word.
They keep their word when they say yes, yes.
No, no.
Pretty much all of my Jewish friends aren't religious at all.
And they're not.
The majority of my friends weren't.
But they would observe Hanukkah and stuff like that.
But they weren't like every day with the Teflon and all that stuff.
They don't follow the rules.
I never, ever had a problem with them.
And I still don't.
But I got a problem when you attack my faith.
You try to paint it in a way that's not true.
You use very powerful machines to do that.
From films like the one we just played.
To everything.
To news and completely dehumanize and distort what my religion actually says.
Like Muslims are the enemies of Jews.
No, my friend.
It was actually Christians that were the enemies of Jews throughout history.
It was Christians that massacred the Jews.
It was the Christians that did the Inquisition.
It was the Christians that did the Holocaust.
It wasn't the Muslims.
What did the Muslims do, my brother?
Pull it up.
It was not the Muslims who pushed the Jews out of ancient Israel.
Okay?
It was who?
Pull it up.
Who destroyed the Second Temple?
Because that's what this whole thing is about.
We're going to get to that now.
Who destroyed the Second Temple, my brother?
Read it, Danny Jones.
My mouth hurts, bro. Read.
What happened?
The Roman army was led by Titus.
Titus overthrew the siege,
oversaw the siege,
and eventually the destruction of Jerusalem,
including the Temple.
The destruction of the Second Temple marked a major turning point in Jewish history.
Okay?
Scroll down. I think we have more on this one.
Do we have more? What does it say?
I thought it was Julian the Apostate.
The bottom line is this, though.
That Temple, okay,
was not destroyed by the Muslims or the Arabs.
No.
By a guy who...
So even before Christianity existed...
He was super anti-Christian, wasn't he?
Yeah. Julian the Apostate.
So the Jews get pushed out. They get wiped out.
They get exiled
from Jerusalem. Completely exiled.
Had nothing to do with Muslims.
Okay?
Who brings them back to Israel even back then, bro?
Read it.
What does it say?
When Muslim forces took Jerusalem
from the Byzantine Empire,
Jews had been largely barred from living
in the city under prior Christian rule.
After the surrender, policies
under Oman
permitted Jews
to live in Jerusalem again.
He went there and he said
he was the second king of the Muslims
after Abu Bakr.
So first was the Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon him.
Then it was
Omar. Omar was
the caliphate that was in power.
The king of the Muslims as Islam expanded.
They conquered Jerusalem
with minimal blood loss.
Okay? It was actually negotiated, the surrender.
What does he do?
He says, are there any Jews here?
They said no.
He says we can't have a Jerusalem without Jews.
He makes them bring him 80,
up to 80 families and resettles them back
after being banned for hundreds of years.
This is only
5 years after the life of the Prophet Muhammad
if I'm not mistaken, peace be upon him.
It's only 5 years after the Prophet died.
Why if Islam is such an evil religion
that hates Jews
like that clown you had on your show,
he says they wiped them out.
What's his name?
Jason Giorgiani.
Would they, in less than 5 years
after the life of the Prophet Muhammad,
peace and blessings be upon him,
would the second caliphate
purposely go and bring Jews and bring them back?
Can you explain that one to me?
If it's in our doctrine,
because we're at the beginning there.
We're not 500 years later.
We're talking about from its inception.
They push these narratives in the media
that Muslims are programmed to hate Christians and wipe them out.
They quote quotes out of context.
People like Laura Loomer.
People like Fox News.
Where they give half of a sentence of the Quran.
Not even the full verse.
And try to make it seem like our objective
is to wipe out anyone that's a non-believer
when the non-believers the Quran is talking about
are not Christians or Jews.
Christians and Jews have a protected class in Islam
and in the holy book of the Quran.
They are known as the people of the book.
They are to be protected
when living under Muslim rule
as Muslims protected Jews from day one.
And I speak out.
Not because I ever want to talk about these topics.
I'm sick and tired of talking about it.
But it's the only move they have.
To blame Muslims, blame Arabs.
Keep pushing these policies
so they can keep sending our sons and daughters
to go fight their fucking wars, bro.
And I will not be silent anymore.
They can kill me, take my life. I don't care.
I've seen what war does.
I know what it's like to get a phone call
and a massacre.
I will be damned if I stay silent.
It'll take my life.
If you're watching, do it.
You're gonna die anyway.
But at least die speaking the truth.
Their whole life from our inception
all we ever did was protect them.
Even throughout Europe.
Pull up how were Jews treated in Muslim Spain, bro.
What is this story about how they're saying
that they want to destroy the dome of the rock
or something like this
to build this third temple.
What's this all about?
The Muslims didn't destroy the temple.
That stood where Solomon's temple was.
Solomon is a very important prophet.
Peace and blessings be upon him.
And I covered this in our
God, Aliens, and the Demonic Rome episode.
So if you're watching this
and you really want to know what the fuck is going on
go check out Danny Jones' episode
God, Aliens, and the Demonic Rome.
You'll thank me later.
Don't watch if you're a Scientologist.
Now, with that said
that spot, okay,
it was very important to
anyone that believed in the God of Abraham.
Solomon's temple, okay?
The Romans
took out the temple, right?
It wasn't the Muslims.
When we reconquered, not reconquered,
conquered Jerusalem,
we brought the Jews back,
the temple mount, there was nothing there.
There was debris and rubble.
Omar started actually, the king of the Muslims
started grabbing the debris with his own hands
and started clearing up the temple mount.
And then they built
the Al-Aqsa Mosque.
But whenever they mention the Al-Aqsa Mosque
they never show you its picture.
They always show you the Dome of the Rock.
They want people, including Muslims,
to not even know that they're not talking about
the real Al-Aqsa Mosque.
The Al-Aqsa Mosque is not the Dome of the Rock.
The Al-Aqsa Mosque is to the right
of the Dome of the Rock
on the temple mount.
And I believe, very soon,
probably an Iranian missile,
conveniently,
will hit that mosque.
Which other meaning, by the way,
Al-Aqsa means the end in Arabic.
The end.
The rapper,
Immortal Technique,
when they found out what was buried under Solomon's
temple, Al-Aqsa, their name is not
coincidental. He says in his
lyrics, Immortal Technique, the point of
no return. Shout out to Immortal Technique, man.
You don't know me yet, but you will.
I'm on Danny Jones' podcast.
Show me the Al-Aqsa Mosque.
The temple mount.
I believe
they had to fulfill the
extremists of their religion. We're dealing with extremists,
not all Jews. Anyone that's saying
all Jews are evil, you're fucking evil.
Anyone saying all Muslims is evil,
you're fucking evil. Anyone saying
all Christians are evil, you're evil.
Anyone putting an entire population of race,
nationality, creed into one box,
you are the problem with humanity.
That is not, see,
this is not the Al-Aqsa Mosque.
What is that, the Dome of the Rock?
Let me show these pictures instead,
where the Al-Aqsa Mosque is that one,
to the left of it.
That's tiny as fuck.
It's the ancient mosque
that was built on the rubble
of the Solomon Temple. So that's the third temple.
That was destroyed by the Romans.
So remember, the Muslims also
believe in Solomon and David,
peace be upon them. They weren't called Jews.
There was no word for Jew back then.
They were Israelites. We believe the
Israelites submitted to the God of Abraham.
We believe that the Israelites were given
the word of God. They were chosen, as they say,
but not above all of humanity.
And we're all just gory.
They were chosen by
God, by Allah,
Allah, Elohim,
was chosen by
God to deliver the message
to humanity.
Abraham had two sons.
This is Islam
in a nutshell.
One side was the Israelites.
One side was the Arab
nation, or what they call Hashem.
We do believe
that the Israelites were chosen
by God, because Abraham was
the father of the majority of the prophets.
Peace and blessings be upon him.
One of God's most beloved.
He chose the Israelites
to deliver the word. He sent them
the Torah. He sent them the Psalms
of David. And then he
sent their greatest son, who they
denied. He sent
Jesus Christ. Peace and blessings
be upon him. Who was the Messiah?
Correct.
Christ came with his gospel, which was
his spoken word. The gospel was real, but
we never had it preserved during his lifetime.
It was compiled 40 to 300
years after his alleged crucifixion.
And regular, common
Christians didn't have access to the Bible
until the printing press in the 1500s.
So imagine being a follower
of Christianity, and you didn't even have access to your holy
book until 1500
years later.
And we don't need to go down that
wormhole, but
the way it was compiled, the
Holy Quran is a miracle, bro.
Only an asshole can see, but where am I going with this?
Because of their
chopping John the Baptist's head off,
peace and blessings be upon John the Baptist.
He's one of the most righteous servants of God.
He's mentioned by name in the Holy Quran.
John the Baptist was
killed, decapitated,
and then they tried to humiliate
the Messiah. When they
did this, they were cut off from Revelation.
And then God
crossed over to the other side of Abraham
to deliver the final testimony.
That's what the Quran is. It's the last
testament. We believe in the Old Testament.
We believe in the Psalms of David.
We believe in the Gospel of Christ, which was not
preserved. We know that the Torah was
corrupted. We know that they changed
the passages.
And that is why we believe that the Quran is like
the filter. It came last to rectify
everything that came before it.
And God made the book in such a way
that anyone could memorize it. Ramadan
just ended, Danny. And for
30 days, I stood in a mosque
and watched. And even that guy, what's the guy's
name again? Jorjani. Admitted that the book
has never changed since his inception.
He says it on that episode, you deal with him. So,
I thank you for being truthful about that.
And a kid
can memorize it, bro. I met
21-year-olds that had just finished completing
their certification. Because you don't get to just call yourself
a Hafiz. A Hafiz is someone
without looking at the Quran
can start from the first passage to the end
because of the way it's recited.
Let's pull up. Well, that's the other thing that he was bringing up
was that it's a theocracy
in the Caliphate.
Children are brought up
in schools and they're
taught the Quran. They're taught to memorize the Quran.
They can wipe out the whole book. It's baked into
education and it's baked into
politics and government. But this
is what you need to understand.
That book can be memorized, which
is why God left all the other books in
our custody. I'm talking about humanity.
And we altered passages and
we changed things. Yeah, it's deceptive.
It's counterintuitive. So, we believe he compiled
that book. It's not because I care to push
Arab culture.
Or any of that stuff.
They're gonna be judged twice as hard based on Islam
because the book came in their language.
So, for us, to me
as someone that's non-Arab,
the miracles I've seen in that book, bro,
the way it's recited, the way it
sounds, whether I
understand the words or not,
it'll move anyone. It'll move anyone if they
just listen to it. We
know that that final book came
through the other side of Abraham. That's why
when Muslims go to Mecca,
uh,
Danny. Is that the video you showed me last night?
Yeah. It's in my stories probably still.
I could pull it up. So, that is the
largest gathering of human beings on
earth. Show that. Show the gathering at the
site of Mecca. Okay. Pull it up.
Pull up to one of my stories. Go to my ex. It's crazy.
Okay.
What you need to understand is we don't go there
to pray. First of all, Muslims
don't pray to Muhammad. We only pray to
God alone.
We don't have statues. We don't pray to
saints. We don't pray to anyone. Now, there's a lot of
Shias that pray to Ali, okay,
which is not Orthodox Islam. You're not
allowed to pray to anyone but God himself.
At that point, you've joined the ranks
of people that pray to saints
and anyone else but God. Orthodox
Islam, you're not allowed to pray
to anyone on earth except to God,
the creator of the earth, the heavens and the earth.
The reason we go to Mecca
once a year, brother, getting back to Abraham,
is we believe this is where God commanded
Abraham, peace and blessings be upon him,
to take his wife and leave him there
with her baby.
And it was a desert. There was nothing there.
A brutal desert.
And as he left, Abraham
rose his hands and said, oh God, make it a
place of sanctuary and security for them.
Because it was a test. Imagine taking one of your
wives and her suckling baby and leaving
them in the middle of a hot desert. Because God told you to.
But Abraham was one of the most
loyal to God. As
he did that, she
was searching. Pull up right there
to the right. Go down, down, down.
Right. Okay? That one?
Yes. This is
the largest. One million Muslims.
This is the largest, most powerful
vortex in the world. That is
fucking bananas. Okay? Everyone's
dressed in white because
in the sight of God, it doesn't matter
what race you are,
what color you are, how much money you
have. When we all go back to him,
we go with nothing, Danny Jones.
The founder of OnlyFans couldn't
bring a dollar with him, could he, Danny?
Yeah. This is a place that took a man
like Malcolm X who hated anybody that wasn't white.
He was racist against white people.
And you can't blame him for living in that type of America.
This is the crazy thing to me is that
you know, it's the, say what you want
about it, it is, it's a fact that
it's the second biggest religion in the world. There's like
two billion Muslims in the world. We're almost number one, brother.
And the prophecies are true.
And you think it's true that
Islam will be the majority religion
by 2075?
Yes, it will. Christians are not having
kids, bro. I have always said this. I wish
America would be a Christian nation.
I pray that America becomes a Christian
nation. I pray they go back to morality
and what the Bible teaches them to have children
to be married, to not have sex
out of wedlock, to not allow
abominations. So when you have people like
Charlie Kirk, may God have mercy on his soul,
who was saying Islam
is not compatible with the West. Well, what's the
definition of the West? Is it
to be 60% of our children
born out of wedlock? Look at how society
is going. Is that what we're trying to accept?
Is it for our daughters to sell
their pussies on OnlyFans?
Is it to be a place of
immorality completely? Is that the kind of world
you want your kids to grow up in? No, definitely not.
Is it a place where 90% of
violent criminals don't know who their father is?
We make music about it. They're laughing.
Who's your daddy? You have Cardi B
going, fuck a man, I got some money.
This is what we want? Our children? So I don't
know. If that's the West that
Charlie Kirk is talking about,
I can say that
Islam is not compatible with the West.
But we're compatible with Christianity.
We're definitely compatible with Christianity.
I pray this nation, and it's begun to,
and that's the only thing that gives me hope
that Americans are returning back
to the church. They're returning back to their Christian roots.
But to say it was founded
as a Christian nation, but what version of Christianity?
The first pilgrims that came
around the Mayflower were a
sect of Protestantism that was
being persecuted by other Protestants.
So who was the founding member?
And was it Christian-like
to wipe out the natives completely?
So my question is, what are we talking about here?
Are we going to be true to facts?
Or are we only going to try to
put shade on Islam and make it look in a way
that's really not true to fact?
So Europeans were
massacring each other for centuries.
Pull it up.
Catholic and Protestant, how many people died
in the Thirty Year War,
in this war, in that war? All over Europe.
Starving to death, killing each other.
Because one said, no,
he's the son of God. No, someone said, no,
he is God. Wiping each other out.
Why am I saying this? It's not to ridicule
the Christian. The point is
Christians didn't even get it ever.
They've been fighting each other since inception.
The Council of Nicaea happened
because they were about to have a civil
war within Christianity between Orthodox
and Catholicism. Because they
couldn't agree. They wiped out the
Ebionites, who were Christians
that didn't even believe Jesus was God.
They believed like we do, that he was a prophet.
So, how many died
just in the Thirty Year War? Forget the entire
history of Europe, because that's been going on forever.
Now it doesn't happen anymore. Do you know why
they don't have these problems anymore?
Because none of them give a shit anymore about their faith.
They're more worried about how to go into
a brothel in Germany. Paradise
is a sauna. Seventy-five dollars to get in.
You get a nice buffet. I've never been there,
but I heard stories. Seventy-five euros.
You get buffet.
They have slot machines. You get drinks.
You can smoke hookah. And then you pick any girl you want.
Which, by the way, if you go to brothels,
if you go to massage parlors,
okay? Strippers,
for the most part, they're just fucking stupid.
And they sell their souls. But if you
go to massage parlors for happy endings,
and you go to brothels,
just know that eighty to ninety percent
of those women are trafficked. Just know
that you are those women, bro.
One hundred percent. Just because it's
legal in Germany doesn't mean that the girls are not forced.
They get kidnapped from all over
the world, okay?
That's true. And they're sold.
So you're going in there as a man thinking you're gonna have fun,
but you're doing it at the expense of
another woman's body, soul, mind,
health, everything, bro. I really pray
that those of you that are watching this, you will never step
foot into a massage parlor that
does happy endings, because that woman is an indentured
servant. She has to do X amount of those
things before they let her leave, if they ever even
let her leave.
I don't let men off the hook
for these crimes, because if there wasn't
anybody paying for these things, these
things wouldn't be happening to these women and children.
And stuff like Epstein wouldn't be
happening, right? How many people
died in the Thirty Year War, bro? How many?
Look at it. Tell me.
4.5 to 8
million lost their lives.
The French Wars of Religion, scroll
down, okay? Was this Christianity?
I'm just asking. Was this Christianity?
Is it Christianity right now that you
think the Ukrainians are Orthodox Christians and
Russians are Orthodox Christians and they're wiping each other out?
That's crazy to me. That should be uniting them,
not making them kill each other. So I don't
blame Christianity for that.
I blame people that call themselves these religions
and they don't follow them.
No more than a terrorist who commits
a violent act that kills.
If you kill an innocent person in Islam, you
burn in hell forever. There's no
72 virgins, none of that shit. You will
burn in hell forever.
That's what Islam
tells you. That's what God tells you.
To save one life is as if you saved
the whole world. To take
one life is as if you've killed the whole world.
All the verses
they quote in the news about Islam are
defensive in nature, but they twist it in a way
to make it look like it's the aggressor. Like
it's there to oppress you. And strike the
non-believers and kill them wherever you can.
It's talking about specific battles
that happened. What does jihad mean?
So the original term of
jihad means to struggle.
And the primary explanation
that the prophet gave for that word was the
struggle a human being has within
themselves to
battle the darkness within yourself.
That's the original terminology
of that word. The secondary
meaning was to battle when
the faith is on the line.
To defend. You gotta remember the
prophet Muhammad and his followers were oppressed for
11 years. Not before
they started attacking. Before they
started responding
to the violence that was being committed against
them. And it was a Christian kingdom
that took them in.
In ancient Abyssinia, which is today
present in Ethiopia, the Najasi,
also known as the Negus,
took in the first Muslims and
gave them refuge while they were being murdered
by their own people and their own families for not
being pagan, for not worshipping a million gods.
11 years before the Muslims
pushed back, when God gave the commandment
do not oppress,
so don't be an oppressor, don't invade people,
and do not be oppressed.
Meaning you have a duty to stand against oppression
and oppressors. You have a moral duty
to stand against injustice.
And I think we have that duty as Americans.
Even within our own borders.
To see this level of corruption.
That I had to change my tires
twice already in New Jersey.
Because of the potholes.
As they take $26
out of my Easy Pass account
to cross a bridge that my tax money
and your tax money already paid for.
That toll used to be $6
when I was 20 years old, Danny.
I'm 43.
Property tax.
Income tax. You got assholes talking about
Jizya tax. The Muslims have a tax.
Bro, people would wish
they had that tax, bro.
Do you know what Jizya tax was? No.
You were under the Muslims. Pull it up, please.
And please go back to the history of how the
Jews were treated in Spanish Spain.
I'm sorry, in Muslim Spain.
Because it's important. It's all connected.
To show the lies. To show the propaganda.
To show the agenda.
To make Christians focus
on Muslims instead of those that have
manipulated them. Destroyed this
nation from within.
Exported all our jobs to China.
Okay? We can't let China off the hook either.
Outsourced. Why did our families fight in the
Korean War? Why did they fight in Vietnam?
To fight against communism, right? And then we
open the floodgates to a communist nation.
And make it a superpower.
That maybe one day we're gonna have to fight, bro.
Or maybe there won't even be a fight.
So,
in the Jizya
system, anyone that is a non-Muslim
would have a protected class
and all they have to pay
is two point
five percent of their total
income to live
freely amongst the Muslims.
Including Jews that were hunted down,
massacred, murdered, treated like shit
as I proved earlier on this episode.
You can go verify yourselves.
We're allowed to live in Andalusia.
Pull up Andalusia on the Renaissance
in Spain under Muslim rule.
Okay? And what did that mean?
Practice your religion.
Live in security. Don't have to fight
if they're invaded or are in war.
So, I as a Jew could pay two point five percent
would you take a flat two point five
right now, Danny?
Would you take, as an American,
if I said, United States of America
is gonna be exactly the same, but all you're gonna
pay every year is two point five percent. For what?
No tolls, no tax, just a flat
rate of two point five on your income.
Would you take that deal right now?
Fuck yeah. Would you take
a flat rate of two point five percent
and you never have to serve in the military either?
Hell yeah. Would you take that as an American?
Yeah. So is that so fucking evil?
What nation didn't have a tax system during
this time? What empire didn't
have a tax system? You see this new guy
But you know what the Christians did?
Twenty, thirty, forty percent
to the Jews, up to eighty
percent of their income if they felt like taking it.
There's this new guy running for governor in California
Fishback is his last
name, and he said he wants to bring in
an OnlyFans tax. He wants to tax
OnlyFans people fifty percent of their income.
And he also wants to completely do a full
on moratorium on immigration.
And he's from
Colombia.
Up to
five, depending on what time
in history. But generally the average is like
two to three percent. The Jizya poll tax
on non-Muslims applied to Christians
and Jews. Typically
a fixed annual amount, not a percentage.
Historic estimates.
No, so the change depends on how much
money you made. And Muslims paid more.
Muslims had to give two point five percent no matter
what to charity to take care of the less fortunate.
And they still had to pay tax.
Up to five to ten percent. So we were paying more
taxes.
Look at how debunked this is, Danny. They talk about
Jizya. If the Muslims took over and this and that.
So why would I have to pay this tax?
Because you're a citizen under the empire.
Just to be a citizen?
Just to be a citizen. Are you not paying taxes right now?
And there's no other taxes?
Brother, they're taking half our shit, bro.
And if you don't take it, they'll throw you in jail.
By the way, who's excluded from that?
Priests, rabbis, children, women
don't have to pay. Only
working age men were the only ones required to pay it.
Would you take that deal, Danny?
I'd make that deal.
Two point five, five max.
You never have to fight in battle.
Your wife doesn't get taxed if she makes money.
Your kids don't get. Only you have to pay if you're
because you're a man. You're part of the empire.
Jews were protected
throughout history.
They had golden ages under Muslim rule.
Throughout history. It was a Muslim
majority country of Albania that saved them
during the Holocaust.
And then you have them in the last thirty, forty, fifty years
in this narrative that Muslims hate Jews.
Muslims want to wipe out Jews.
If it wasn't for Islam and Muslims, there probably wouldn't be
a single Jew on earth or they all would have ended up
in Asia over there if they would have allowed them to go.
They should be ashamed of themselves.
Randy Fine should be ashamed of himself.
Laura Loomer, you should be ashamed of yourself.
Any Jew that's pushing this narrative
that Islam is the enemy of Jews
should be ashamed of themselves.
The history's there and I challenge your audience
to go read it. Pull up how they were treated.
Just type in.
How were Muslims treated? How were Jews
treated?
By Muslims compared to Christians
throughout history. Go ahead.
Pull it up. So that's what I'm saying. Where's this term
Judeo-Christian? Judeo-Christian
values? It doesn't exist.
Christians hated Jews
and if you think that they forgot
all these centuries of fucking violence,
no, when they said never
again, they meant they're never going to take it from anyone
ever again. It wasn't about stopping
Holocaust and stopping genocide
that had been happening all over the world
that we didn't even talk about.
Never again meant for them only, bro.
But yeah, Christians, you're right. Hate the Muslims.
Hate everyone.
Wipe them out. I gotta pee real quick.
Alright, we're back. Where were we?
We were talking about the
lies. How they take
history, completely twist it.
No one does research so they just eat it up and believe
this narrative that Muslims are
the enemies of Jews when all we've done is protect
them throughout history, bro.
Up until World War II,
bro.
You wanna talk about Muslim Spain,
like the Muslims conquered Spain. First of all, it wasn't
even called Spain back then. It was called the Goth Kingdom.
And the Goth Kingdom was in the middle
of a civil war. And half of the
kingdom invited the Muslims in
to take over. And when they do,
a beautiful place was created. It was called
Andalusia. If you pull up
the history of Andalusia, it was
the greatest society in the entire world
at the time, while much of Europe was still
in the Dark Ages. Pull up the
history of Andalusia.
So what does this say here?
Treatment of Christians and Muslims ruled Spain.
Andalus was neither uniformly
tolerant nor uniformly oppressive. It shifted over
time, depending on who was in power, blah, blah, blah.
Scroll down.
What about Sharia
law? So, Sharia
law. Something that's open to interpretation,
bro. Okay?
So, you have people like, especially out of
Texas, they were attacking the Plano Mosque,
the epic masjid
under the
you know, the community that's living there
I just went there, bro. What an amazing
community, bro. We made a film. Me and Sonny Faz
that's S-O-N-N-Y
F-A-Z. If you want to check out his channel,
we have a daily show there together.
I saw how Jake Lang and
I believe paid agitators,
the same way Antifa was paid
in my opinion, because none of that
made sense, are
paid to create this narrative that Muslims
are taking over America. They have a secret
agenda and plan to take over the whole country
and force everybody to become Muslim
and Sharia law.
That couldn't be further from the truth.
You have politicians like Governor Abbott of
Texas, the clown,
stating that
Sharia law is going to be banned in Texas.
How can you ban something that's not officially
the law? Can you explain that one to me?
If it's not the law, and we're
not operating the state of Texas by
Sharia law, then why does it need to be banned?
There's nothing Sharia in the
law. Even though many of the rules and regulations
we have in our constitution,
the way we run our society would be classified
as Sharia, right? Having a
trial by jury, stuff like that.
It's open to interpretation.
You've had bad rules throughout history. You've had a lot
of great rules throughout history.
Sharia law
is, first of all,
anything that the Prophet said, that we
know he said, is how we're supposed to
basically operate.
Do you want
to cover this part first, or do you want to get into
the whole Sharia thing and keep it going?
Let's get into the Sharia thing, bro.
Pull up
what did the Prophet Muhammad
teach?
Did the Prophet Muhammad teach Muslims to
obey the rulers
when they live in foreign lands?
Let's see what it pops up.
Because that's
what the Prophet Muhammad commanded, peace be upon him.
When Muslims live in a society that's not
ruled by them, they're supposed to obey
the government, the people,
and be thankful to
that society for allowing them to live there.
They're not there to create chaos.
They're not allowed to create
any type of issues in that society.
That is what the Prophet Muhammad taught
his followers.
So, that's Sharia.
So, as a Muslim,
we have to obey the rules and regulations
of the United States of America,
the federal laws, state laws,
and
as long as we're allowed to practice
our faith, we're not allowed to
disrupt that society or destroy that
society or try to make it
get overthrown, as they paint
these false narratives in the media,
again, to dehumanize Muslims, create
hatred so Americans focus their energy more on Muslims
than what the real fucking problem is.
The lobbies.
The unlimited terms in Senate and Congress.
Is there a Muslim lobby?
The endless laws. I think there is.
You should look that up.
Maybe CARE would count as that, the Council of
American Islamic Relations,
which the Governor Abbott just deemed
a terrorist organization.
And their job is basically
if Muslims are being attacked
or
defamed or dehumanized,
they're supposed to help those
people out. There are several organizations
and coalitions in the USA that
represent Muslim interests, often engaging
in lobbying, civil rights advocacy, and
political activism. They do not
operate as a single monolithic
lobby. The most prominent group
is the Council on American Islamic
Relations, CAIR. Yep, you were right.
I promise you they're not spending
the kind of money that AIPAC is.
You know?
So, in
2024, lobbyists
spent $4.2
billion
soliciting our
Congress and Senate.
$4.2 billion. By the way, speaking of
outlawing prostitution, that's the most
blatant form of prostitution there is.
It's legal bribery, brother.
It's legal bribery that has
corrupted this nation from the inside out.
It's why all of our industry and jobs
ended up overseas.
It's why our country entered the World Trade Organization.
It's why so many countries
got our military technology.
Some of it was given willingly,
some of it was stolen. By the way, where's all of our
great military black budget technology?
I don't know. Like, this war
is fucked.
We don't have any kind of crazy, like,
super gravity, or...
I'm sure we have crazy stuff, but if you use it,
you wipe out all the civilians.
Right? Yeah. I'm pretty sure we have some crazy
stuff. So,
could you pull up what the Prophet Muhammad...
Did the Prophet Muhammad order Muslims
to live peacefully in
non-Muslim...
nations? Let's see. What did
the Prophet teach us? I don't want to hear
about... I want to hear what did the founder
of the religion teach his followers?
I have proven over the last
two hours plus
Jews and Christians are protected,
respected, not supposed
to be oppressed. They paid a minimal tax
to live freely in those societies.
Okay? I've demonstrated it all with
receipts. You're more than welcome to be educated
for once in your life. Instead of
consuming the goy slop. I love when people
go, well,
Trump, famous for saying,
it's fake news. It's all fake
news. I agree, Mr. President.
It is all fake news.
If it was fake enough for you and all the
people that vow their allegiance to you,
if something like that can be corrupt
once, then it's corrupt for everything.
Why should it be so crazy to think that
I, as a Muslim, am telling you the same
way you believe it's fake news for everything
else when it's convenient for you? If it was
fake for you, this Muslim is here
to tell you that it's been fake about our
religion since day one, bro.
But ask yourself, who controls that media
and why would it be in their interest to
dehumanize Arabs and Muslims
so that they can send your sons and daughters to
war in places like Iraq, Afghanistan,
in places like
Iran,
okay? So, what do you say?
By the way, I'm curious to know also,
What did he teach? Let's
cover this. It's important. Okay, let's cover it. What did he teach?
Break it down for us back. Muslims must
live peacefully in non-Muslim countries in those
exact terms.
Let's go down. One of the clearest
historical precedents is the migration, I mentioned
this earlier, of Abyssinia. Muhammad
sent a group of his followers, they were being
persecuted in Mecca, they were being killed
by their own clansmen, their own
families, and he said, go to this
kingdom, there are righteous Christians.
How could the Quran
command people to
kill Christians, which it does not.
Christians are never mentioned as infidels in the
Holy Quran. Not a single passage
are they referred to as
the infidels. The infidels, the Quran is talking
about are the pagan Arabs that were trying
to kill the first Muslims. You
can only put it into context at that time
during those battles.
It wasn't for the whole world.
It wasn't for Muslim domination
of the earth. It was for
those battles during that time
where their own people turned on them and tried to wipe
them out. On the
contrary, the Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon him, sent
the first Muslims to ancient Abyssinia
where they were protected by a Christian
king, a righteous Christian king known as the
Najasi. If Islam
was taught by the Prophet Muhammad to hate Christians
and kill Christians, then why would he send his followers
in the most crucial time to a Christian kingdom?
Does that make any sense to you, Danny
Jones? Scroll down.
God
does not forbid you from being kind and just to
those who do not fight you because of religion.
Surah 68, meaning they fight you.
Chapter 2, 256 of
the Holy Quran, there is no compulsion in religion.
There is no forcing people
into faith. Surah 4,
chapter 135, and stand firmly
for justice even if it's against your
self. Those are often interpreted
to mean peaceful non-Muslims should be treated
with fairness and respect. Coexistence is acceptable
and expected,
Danny Jones. Not world domination.
We have a verse in the
Quran called the chapter of the non-believers
and it goes like this.
That's how a white boy learns Arabic, to protect the book,
the final testament of God.
I don't understand Arabic, but I pray in its
language to preserve the book.
So what happened to the Old Testament, what happened
to the Gospel of Christ, could not happen to
the final testament. Every Muslim
on earth sings and recites
the book in Arabic, not because the Arabs are superior
to us. The Prophet said an Arab
is not superior to a non-Arab. A black
over a white, except through
piety, except for being righteous. That's what makes
you better than someone. Not their skin color,
not what nation they were born to.
God says in the Holy Quran, I could have made
you all one nation humanity,
but I want to see how stupid you would be
if I made you different colors.
Meanwhile, we all bleed the same color and
side, brother. Anyone that's racist
can't call themselves a Christian, Muslim, or a Jew.
Because Adam and Eve gave
life to every color and every
people of the nation, of the
world. So,
important limitation,
right? Peaceful coexistence emphasized
where there's no persecution, right? So as long as
you're not being murdered, hunted down, you have a right to defend yourself
always, okay? And governments turn on their
people all the time, brother, okay?
And as long as you are allowed to
practice your faith, which you are in this beautiful,
amazing country of ours,
okay? This beautiful, amazing
nation, where so many different people
can come, and we have this beautiful
melting pot and fusion
and different cultures and food,
there's no reason for Muslims
to rebel in America. At all.
It's forbidden. Because
we're allowed to practice our faith.
We're allowed to go to a mosque on Friday
and worship God. But what does it do?
We can open a halal restaurant. And all
halal means is sanctioned by God.
It means the animal,
just like kosher, same exact term, no
ban halal. If we started saying ban
kosher, you'd be thrown in prison.
You'd be called an anti-Semite. Meanwhile,
halal follows the same exact structure
as kosher, by the way, as far as
how the animal is slaughtered.
We believe God created certain animals
to be eaten. The pig is not one of them.
And it's not just because the pig can be considered filthy
and has parasites. That animal
cannot be
slaughtered in a way where it does not suffer
enormously compared to animals
like the cow or the lamb
or the chicken. When you
cut the neck of a
lamb or a sheep or a cow,
they die instantly.
They might have some spasms,
but they die instantly. And all
of their blood drains from the meat. What about pigs?
Pigs, ask any butcher, they
squeal. They die very close
to like a human being would.
They suffer enormously
when they die. They were not created by the
Creator for consumption. It's not just about
cleanliness with them. Animals have
rights. Islam is very strict on
how animals should be treated.
Animals have the utmost respect in Islam
because they're a gift from God.
Trees have respect in the religion of Islam.
You're not allowed to cut down a tree unless
you absolutely need it.
So this is a faith that believes in
protecting the environment. That animals
have respect. That these are gifts that were endowed
to mankind, humankind,
by the authority of God.
That we have a duty and responsibility to the
earth that God left us to entrust,
entrusted to us and to every living
creature on this earth. We are
the ones that rule
the earth. So we have a responsibility to
these gifts of God. So
the pig is not eaten. Not because
it don't taste good. Because people
tell me bacon's no joke. I mean last night
I had one meal by Bax. Oh yeah,
you had some bacon last night, Bax. I spit it right out.
We ordered a seafood
dish. Scallops. Scallops
with bacon. And underneath it was a bed of bacon.
God damn it was delicious. Because I didn't look at the menu. I'm like,
why does this taste smoky?
Spit it right out. You looked at me like I was crazy.
So yeah, we don't eat pork.
And if it wasn't done on purpose, God doesn't hold
it against you. I didn't try to eat pork. Okay.
The only time a Muslim can eat pork is if they're
absolutely starving and there's nothing else around.
It says even in the Quran, if you have nothing
else to sustain yourself, then you're allowed to.
Okay. Because your life takes precedence over
the rule.
So, you know,
basically, like I said, if you read this,
he commanded them, if you live somewhere,
you must live in peace. You must obey the rules,
the regulations, the laws.
You must obey that
ruler, which at this time was kings.
Yeah. Right? So
where they come up with all this nonsense, Danny,
as I've demonstrated for the last almost
three hours now we're going in,
is that they need to paint these narratives,
to dehumanize two billion people
who are against the very industries
that they own. And because Islam
is spreading like a wildfire, the more
hatred they spew out, the more
people are becoming Muslim. Do you know why? How many people are converting
to Islam? Oh, no one even knows. Every
mosque I walk into, I see it almost
every time I walk into one. How often do you go into a mosque?
Once a week at least. Really? Yeah.
Every Friday we have communal prayer. Do you stick a
stick to the same mosques, or do you just try out new mosques?
Well, now I'm all over the place, thanks to you and Julian Dory
and... Have you been to a mosque
in Florida? Yeah, I went to one
the day I landed, yesterday. Really? I went to
what's called Omar Mosque, right
here in Tampa, downtown Tampa. I went to pray
the night prayer there. A lot of Spanish
reverts in there, a lot of Latinos, it's spreading
Really? It's spreading like a wildfire. And when you
talk to them, when you talk to like new converts,
what do they say? Sonny Fazz is a
great example of a new person.
He's only been a Muslim for two years, bro.
The kid makes me look like a
joke when it comes to this faith, bro.
I've never seen someone so
passionate about the religion of Islam, bro.
He's caught a lot of backlash from
his own family. They make fun
of him. They piss at him.
He said he came from a family that wasn't even really
religious at all until he decided
to become a Muslim. And then they became religious.
Yeah, you know. Remember,
we don't abandon Jesus Christ, we just have him in a
different position, right? He's on the team,
we just don't have him as the head coach.
We have him as the quarterback.
Peace and blessings be upon him.
His mother has
her own chapter in the book. He's the quarterback.
Yeah, because he comes in fourth quarter, bro.
He comes in at the end of the game.
Right? So we also believe
that Jesus Christ is the
anointed one, which is what the word Messiah means.
He's mentioned by
name in the Quran. He's called
the Messiah by name
in the Quran. We
believe he comes back towards the end of time
to fight against and destroy the Antichrist.
Do you think the Jews
could bring back Jesus like they say they want
to do?
They're not going to bring him back.
They're waiting for a Messiah.
They didn't accept the Messiah that God
sent. They accepted, they accepted,
they wanted to. I thought the point of all this
stuff, according to the professor
Jang Pak's Judaica theory, was that they needed
to sow chaos around the world
in order to bring Christ
back to earth in Megiddo.
Well, there's a lot of Christian Zionists that follow
that philosophy, too. They feel like by helping
Israel. The evangelicals, yeah.
By helping Israel,
do what it's doing, they're going to speed up the
second coming and they're going to get raptured.
They're going to get brought back to heaven. You think that you're going to force
God's hands? God,
God says in the Quran, you plan
and God plans. But
God is the best of planners.
You can play your games. So
they didn't accept the Messiah. I as a Muslim
will tell you, I love Jesus Christ with
all of my heart. His
mother was the most important woman in our faith.
She has her own chapter in the Quran.
It's called Mary. It's about
the Virgin Mary. Peace and blessings be upon her.
Look at the reverence we have to give
just by mentioning her name.
Christians don't do that. We say
Mary, we say peace be upon her.
We say Jesus, respect. Peace
be upon him. One of the
mightiest messengers of God
who will be sitting on the right side of God as the Bible
says. Right side meaning, hey, you're
sitting in front of me, but hey, Danny Jones is my right hand
man, right? You could
be sitting on my left, but if I say to you,
Danny Jones, he's a good dude. He's a stand up
dude. He's my right hand man.
We also believe Jesus will be on the right hand
of God. What do you think happens
when you die? I think
the angels of death come, and that's
when all of you that denied, the one that
created all of us, the ones
of you that think that all of this happened by
accident, yet your own bed won't make itself in
the morning. Those of you that
deny the heart that beats within your
body, that beeps and beats and beats
a hundred thousand beats a day without
you commanding it to because it's called the
respiratory system, and you breathe
air in and release the air,
the carbon dioxide that
you can't consume, right? You need oxygen to
live, and you watch the rain
through the process of evaporation
because it's called a
ecosystem, and millions and millions
of systems that are in order
cannot come out of thin air.
You
have no other examples of things just coming
randomly out of chaos.
You can see the design if you
live long enough on this earth. The cycles
and the systems that are in place for
you to even be listening to me right now,
Danny. And that's why I do believe
there's a heaven and hell. You deny the one
that gave you this gift,
this existence,
consciousness. We are
in a simulation, Danny Jones,
but it's a simulation that the creator created,
and he will destroy the simulation
when it's over. We believe in Islam
when God destroys the earth, he destroys the entire
universe. He kills everything
that lives in every single dimension because
there are other dimensions, and we covered this in that episode.
Like I said, God aliens in the demonic
realm. The demonic realm,
I believe, we're not dealing with Jews
here. We're not dealing with
evil Christians and evil Muslims.
We are dealing with
an elite class that works
with the demonic realm.
They are aligned with Satan and
his minions. I believe
they are preparing us. You think
Trump is religious? I don't think
he's religious, Beau. I think
they're preparing us for an alien
invasion, which is nothing more than what the
Christians would call the bottomless pit,
that they figured out a way scientifically
to open a portal to the parallel dimension
that they live in. And that
these demons, which also shapeshift,
that's why some of these explanations
that people have, the reptilians, the
Palladians, and all this fucking nonsense,
and Billy Carson.
Hey, don't talk mean about Billy Carson.
Listen, I ain't talking mean. My man's delusional.
Everything he thinks he's teaching people,
we already had. I would call him more a Scientologist
than anything else, in my opinion. In my opinion.
Because that's what they believe. Aliens
created us and altered us.
Okay? So
us, people that believe in the God
of Abraham, Christians, Muslims,
and Jews, we believe in Satan.
We believe in his army.
We believe he declared war on humanity
before God even blew the soul into Adam's
body. Peace and blessings be upon him. The first
human being that ever walked the Earth.
That even modern science says we all had one
common ancestor. They can't rule
it out, Danny Jones. They can't rule it out.
What is Satan? Satan is
a member of the Djinn, a species that's
created from a smokeless flame.
Some of us have ideas and guesses that
they may be made from some type of plasma,
or electric current. We don't know exactly, but
God describes them as a smokeless flame.
Angels are made from
light. And us human beings, if you look at
your skin, you'll see we're made from all the different
colors of the Earth. This is almost
like a sand color.
You have people that are literally,
their skin is the color of the rich mud.
Right? I mean, literally every color
of the red clay of the Indians.
So,
God gave us authority over this Earth.
That species lived on Earth before
humanity fell from the heavens when Adam
fell. From grace,
with Eve, they were on Earth
before us. The war was declared on humanity
in the heavens, my brother. This battle's
been going on ever since. And these
people that we're talking about, I would not call
them Jewish. These
people are aligned with the demonic
realm. You can call them Satanists, you can
call them Illuminati, you can call them whatever the fuck
you want. They go to Bohemian Grove
to worship these beings.
They do rituals that they probably
did with Epstein to worship
and show loyalty to this
dimension. And
much of the technology we have gotten is not
alien in the way they're trying to make it sound.
It's alien because
it was passed down through black magic
and rituals. That's how Jack Parsons
figured out how to go to space.
One of Aleister Crowley's key
disciples is literally the reason why
satellites have occupied
our skies.
And if you think Elon Musk is on our
side, go watch
Terminator 2 and
our best case scenario would be
because that's what he's building.
He's building Skynet. It's for the
Antichrist system. It's for the
Dajjal system where no human being can
escape the web, the internet of things.
What does a web do? World
wide web. It entangles
its prey, Danny. There's no escape.
That's what the internet is.
The world
wide web. And
if you put in digital currency with that, my
friend, there will be no escape. So what's coming for us
is coming for all of, not just
America, the whole world. America
was used like the mafia uses a hitman
to set up the global agenda.
And now while we were busy
enjoying our drinks and let's
go Jets! J-E-T-S
Jets, Jets, Jets. Shout out to
the firemen. New York Giants,
New York Jets. Some guy, we had
a dude on here yesterday who was telling us how
American football was created by
the CIA. It's the time.
As a way to pacify human, as the way to
pacify the society. People know more about
that than they do the history of the state they live in.
How crazy is that? Okay. Bread and
circus of the Romans. It's the same tricks,
the same evil, the same battle that
started in the heavens that humanity
has been fighting ever since. The enemy
has always been one, one core enemy,
Danny. Ignorance.
The first passage of the Quran
when the angel Gabriel grabbed the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and said, read.
He was illiterate. He couldn't read and write.
Read. He goes, I cannot read.
Read. Recite. I cannot
read in the name of your
Lord, which created humanity
from a clot of blood in the womb of your
mother. Read because your
creator teaches you that which you
do not know. It
is ignorance why we are
where we are. People
need to wake the fuck up.
Don't listen to me. Go look at everything I
talked about today. Go research it. You'll
see for yourself. If
like I said earlier, he said fake news for everything.
I'm telling you it's fake news.
If it was fake news for Trump, I'm telling you as a Muslim
that's lived in this country my whole life,
it's fake news.
But why is it fake news?
These people are aligned with the devil himself.
I wouldn't call them Jews.
I wouldn't call them Christians. Many of them
mask around as prime ministers and presidents.
Many of them mask themselves around as
the most powerful people of CEOs
of big companies.
They're all together, brother.
This battle's been going on for a long,
long time, bro. They always throw up
their symbol, bro. The one eye.
The Prophet Muhammad said,
I will give you one sign of the
antichrist that no other
prophet gave his nation.
Every prophet based on Islam,
God sent prophets and messengers
throughout the earth, throughout time.
We don't even know all their names. We know the key players.
Noah of the ark, Abraham,
John the Baptist. We know all the big ones.
But there's many prophets and messengers
we don't even know their names. All we know is that
Muhammad was the last. He brought the final revelation,
which is the Quran.
Right? So,
we know that
they all warned their nations of the day
of the end of times and that there would be
a man in human form
that claims to be God himself.
And he will come at a time when the world is in great chaos.
I believe there's an agenda
to create so much chaos and hatred
towards the Jewish community that they're all forced
to leave.
And I don't want to lose my Jewish friends.
I don't want to lose my Jewish friends.
Half of them are in Miami now.
I don't want to lose my friends in Boca.
I don't want to lose my brothers and sisters
that I grew up with in Brooklyn.
I don't want my cousins to maybe feel
a certain way and leave.
We are living in a time
where I believe the agenda is two-stage.
You gotta remember, they're also under propaganda, right?
If I was Jewish, I would not blame them
at all for the way they feel, bro.
You're fed this narrative the entire time.
You think everybody wants to wipe you out.
I clearly proved that we didn't.
Christians, you have more to defend.
We took care of them, bro.
Proved it right here on your show.
So, I do believe
there's an agenda to create such chaos.
I think that's why it's coming out.
They become so uncomfortable,
but they are, bro.
And I feel fucking horrible.
There's a lot of them that just don't even give a fuck
about Israel. They want to live in America, bro.
They don't give a shit. The same reason I live here.
I could go live in Albania.
No, I live here. I'm an American, bro.
I was born here. I love this country.
I like what this country is supposed to be about
and what it's done.
So, do I think that they're in trouble?
I think part of the agenda is to round them all up
and make them so uncomfortable
that they have to go back home.
It definitely seems like that.
That's number one.
Number two, for the prophecies to come true,
they have to be there.
Number three, the mosque cannot be where it is.
The third temple must go up.
I believe the days of Al-Aqsa,
God knows best and all glory and praise
belong to the Creator. Only He knows the future.
But based on analysis,
based on searching things like
Pax Judaica
and listening to lectures
of all types of speakers of different faiths
and I've learned a lot from the Christians too, brother.
I've learned a lot from the Christians.
They're not the same.
I've heard a lot of them
with their prophecies
and a lot of them overlap.
We both believe that there will be a man
that comes at the end of time
pretending to be that he is Christ,
the savior of the world.
They didn't accept him.
They're still waiting for a messiah
so the kind of the puzzle piece kind of fits there.
don't want to get that's a huge amount you tell me how that's a kingdom of god bro
how you pushing this type of filth because not only are you pushing pornography you're pushing
gay pornography okay you're altering people's perceptions of what's reality what's new
it's a big amount eleven to fifteen percent of adults in israel identify as part of the
lgbtq1 out of four bro 25 of the population identifying as part of the lgbtq that's the
holy that's the holy whoa a quarter that's bonkers i have no idea that's crazier than new york bro
oh yeah we never i never asked you about mom dami he's not muslim though he's not allah knows best
he's not no what is he first of all he's of the shia faith which is a minority sect okay
and he's not even following their version of islam you can't say you're a muslim and
sell
he wrote a tweet the other day i forgot it was like two three days ago we need to celebrate the
lgbtq like celebrate you you cannot be a muslim and celebrate that lifestyle so he's not a real
muslim bro to my understanding soros pumped a shitload of money into his campaign soros pull
it up bro oh isn't he jewish in origin pull it up did soros some of his largest donors were jewish
really explain that to me if he's such a threat to jews and i believe he's in power so if a false
lag happens muslim mayor in power the rest is history to what to what campaign mom donnie mom
donnie and soros just type in mom donnie soros let's see if they even met together let's see
if they even have a picture yeah just type in mom dami so i think he was set up because you
don't get to become mayor of new york unless you're very powerful and have a lot of money
oh how much oh george soros did not directly donate to zoron mondami's 25 20 25 nyc mayoral
campaign but his philanthropic network the open society foundation indirectly supported
him by funneling over 37 million to left-wing groups allahu akbar allahu akbar that ran field
operations an atheist a guy that wants to destroy the world a guy that funds pride parades lgbtq
movements okay you explained to me and a jew i don't consider george soros a jew he might be
ethnically what you would classify as ethnically
jewish yeah okay calls himself that but this is a guy that was rounding up jews and throwing them
into ovens exactly okay so this is what i'm saying i don't have any hatred towards jews
i don't have any hatred towards anybody there are radicals in every group of people in the
world there's radicals in sports events danny giants fans will kill philly fans and vice versa
there's extremists in every group on earth philly fans yet they only want to try to make you focus
on the few round apples of two billion people i promise you two billion people were bloodthirsty
we'd have big problems bro does that make sense
now to you when i tell you you think that's a small amount of money he had other donors too
that were that's crazy man if he's so anti-jew we're living in a fake world i believe he's a
plant to create chaos so that the american people can say the muslims but he is not a
representation of islam he is not a representation of muslims anyone that can celebrate what the old
testament calls an abomination now do we have a right to practice that here in the united states of
america they do does it mean i agree with it spiritually i don't do i have friends of that
community bro i'm not gonna lie they're hilarious some of them are awesome like i have a lot
of friends that are and to me when people go do you hate gay people no i'm happy you know what's
mondami's what's the mondami does he does he talk about oh he's a you know his mom was in
the epstein files does he practice did you know his mom was an epstein yeah i saw that so let me
say this do you hate gay people no it's less competition for me if george michaels was
straight bro there wouldn't have been a single woman left on earth
bro does mamdami practice islam he doesn't practice i'm curious to see what he says though
yes mandami democrat new york mayoral candidate identifies as shia muslim and has openly embraced
his faith during his campaign less than 10 percent of muslims fasted during ramadan
back less than 10 percent visits mosques yeah it's all show bro less than 10 percent of muslims
are shia and iran that would be the equivalent of being a jehovah's witness or even a mormon right
i don't even know how many mormons are there's probably even so it's funny to me bro people
can't go we have 20-second tick-tock brains i'm giving you receipts bro they've set the stage
muslim mayor we got a horrible reputation they hired the number one pr company in the world to
try to clean up our greatest allies image and they told us that we're the worst people in the world
we're the worst people in the world we're the worst people in the world we're the worst people
and we can't fix it it's too late the only thing we can do is make the muslims try to make the
muslims look worse than you guys to me seeing laura loomer's tweet all these other people talking
about it congress people that only want to distract they don't care about epstein they don't
care about justice for the world that was shut down for our relatives that were taken out when
the world closed in 2019 with that sickness that spread throughout the earth everyone voted for
trump thinking fauci is going to be in handcuffs yeah my man sped up the process bro operation warps
speed bro operation warp seed controlled op to make you think you had a chance there's no one
coming to save america the only people that can save america are americans remembering what this
country is supposed to stand for remembering our rights and our constitution no matter what
the first and second amendment because if we lose those two nothing else matters my american
brothers and sisters i promise you it's not the muslims that are coming to take that away from you
it is
your god-given right to defend your family your property and your freedom and don't you ever
surrender those rights as someone who lost his family throughout the last hundred years because
they didn't have the means nor the ability to protect and defend themselves my family was
murdered because they didn't even have a weapon when their government turned on them i beg you
my american brothers and sisters whatever the news is telling you to focus on should be the opposite
if you haven't figured that out you're not going to make it to the last level of jumanji you got a
it's just not going to make it bro whoever they're telling you to hate is actually who you should
love and vice versa because it's crazy to me bro the hypocrisy the double standards the lies
imagine like imagine being me danny and you're sitting here you just see this
all day on the news i'm like but that's not what my religion teaches me that's not what
my faith teaches me that's not what the prophet muhammad taught us and you're sitting there
watching this like every day bro it it's about it's very painful like i said i never want to
want to talk about these things but i know where it all goes bro it goes to armageddon it goes to a
war that's going to make world war iii look like a joke it goes to the annihilation of the majority
of this world it goes to i believe it's going to go down that path we're not going to be the
superpower anymore there's something also known as gog and magog it's in the old testament oh yeah
and the quran is called a very evil people that take over the entire earth
and they create chaos and only christ defeats them in the end with the power of god where
are you going if america falls i don't think we survive brother what i think red flashes
i don't think we make it out of this there's no mentioning of the of this place anywhere in the
scriptures bro yet how many signs the prophet muhammad gave that came true he said soon the
shepherds of our people the arabs they're in the middle of the desert nothing there
will compete with one another to make
buildings that touch the sky and when one builds one the other will say i'll make one even bigger
we're all the greatest skyscrapers in the world these are his words danny jones you tell me
how an illiterate arab in pre-ancient arabia okay illiterate could have known that specifically
he said that men will marry men wait what's the answer is it dubai or new york
dubai it's dubai yeah that's what i thought and mecca saudi arabia they're building massive
towers they're going back and forth
qatar dubai okay they're building the biggest structures on earth in the same exact place that
he said it would happen how did he know how do you know if he wasn't well maybe the people that
are building those towers are are reading the quran trying to fulfill a prophecy
danny jones there's a lot of prophecies one of them was the time will come where people
will place instruments musical instruments on their ears and they will dance into the night
how do we explain the verse both social and practical
how did he know he described headphones bro towards the end of time that's pretty wild
that's true all of the minor signs and i invite the audience study the end of time signs in the
religion of islam all the minor ones have happened there's only the big ones left
and what are the big ones the great war the appearance of the antichrist
the return of jesus christ peace and blessings be upon him
it is too late to become a believer in God
because you didn't believe without the signs.
So my message to the Christian audience is
we both believe Christ will be king
when he returns to the earth.
We both believe in one that will claim to be him
and to deceive humanity
and lead them into the fires of hell.
He will be a man that only has one eye.
Why is it that all the elite use that symbol, Danny?
How did the prophet Muhammad know?
Because he's the only one that ever said it.
I will give you a sign of the antichrist
that no other prophet has given his nation
that he will have one eye.
But God does not have one eye.
That was the one description
that the prophet Muhammad gave to all of humanity.
So all of you that are watching
that don't believe in God
and don't believe in religion
and don't believe in faith
and don't believe in Einstein's prophecy,
the closest to the Muslim is the Christian.
I say to you, if you see,
if you survive what's coming next,
if you survive,
if a man,
if a man comes that starts doing miracles,
which I think he will use AI with,
that's the weapon of the antichrist.
What did the prophet Muhammad say?
He will have one eye.
A-I.
How many eyes did he have?
He only had AI.
He only had one eye.
He's building Skynet over our heads, bro,
and we're cheering him on.
Yeah, Skynet, bro.
Starlink, over our heads, bro.
There will be nowhere to escape.
Crypto takes over.
Dollars on its way out.
All fiat currency.
That's why America has to fall.
This is a global agenda.
It's the final act.
They need America.
America was the hitman to set up the board for globalism,
and now what does the mafia do?
Once they take out everyone,
they got to take out the hitman.
We were too busy enjoying our beers and bitches and football
while they were building this system
and our rights were being taken away from us
as Americans and people of the West,
and the UK is horrible right now.
Australia is horrible right now.
They can't even speak certain things
before they get arrested.
It's insane.
So I ask you as a,
as a Westerner,
and I as a Muslim who lives in the West,
I love this nation.
I could go live in those countries.
I don't want to live there.
I want to live in America.
I like being next to non-Muslims
and people of different cultures.
There's been nothing like this on the face of the planet.
So we're losing our freedoms.
We're losing our rights.
So our time is running out
because now the globalists,
they don't need us anymore,
and they want to wipe us out
because now our freedom, Danny Jones,
is standing in the way of their master plan.
We don't have years left.
We have months left.
I hope you're wrong about that.
Months left, in my opinion.
God knows best.
I think there's going to be energy lockdowns
and chaos and mayhem and total financial collapse.
And I've been not just saying it now,
I've been saying this for a couple of years now.
I said this on your show.
I said this on Julian Dory's show.
The only other person that I'm like impressed with
that I've seen speak this way is Sam Tripoli.
I got to watch Kurt's episode,
but I know he knows his shit too
because I listened to him on Jim Dore a lot.
So these are people that are, oh,
they're awake, that understand.
And it's not about Jew, Christian, and Muslim.
There are people disguised as Jews,
disguised as Muslims,
disguised as Christians that are evil,
that are aligned with the demonic realm,
and that's what the fuck is going on.
The cat's out of the bag.
There's no aliens.
We are the aliens.
We were the one cast down.
They lived on this earth before us
and they don't like us, Julian.
They don't like us.
They want to destroy as many of us as they can.
Just call me Julian.
Sorry, my bad.
How fucking dare you?
Kill me.
My bad.
Because I was thinking about clips.
Sorry, man.
Freudian slip.
Back lover.
Julian.
You are a national treasure, brother.
And we also need to remind people before we wrap up,
Epstein was not a Muslim.
Yeah.
And please check out the film, brother, by the way.
We will.
If you can pull it out.
It's called We Explore the Muslim Invasion of America.
It's on Sonny Faz's channel.
They took down the first one.
It was only up for three months.
We were trending on X when we went on the Hodge twins.
They took down the film.
They don't want people to see it.
We debunked Jake Lang.
I met Nick Shirley down in Plano, Texas.
We went to Dearborn, Michigan.
I swear to God, I lied to you now, Danny.
All we do is put on the camera
and show people what was going on there.
I met with the mayor of Dearborn in Dearborn Heights,
which is in the news a lot right now, okay?
Again, they're targeting that community.
They're painting this story that they're,
bro, it was more America than anywhere else I've been, bro.
They had strip club on the main street.
Imagine a place that's under Sharia.
I interviewed local residents that were not Muslim.
How is it living amongst all these Muslims?
What city is this?
Dearborn, Michigan.
Okay, where Jake Lang was going
with his hate protests against Muslims.
And he doesn't have any real followers, bro.
He's got like 30, 40 fucking-
What's the story with Nick Shirley?
He's like working for the administration or something?
He did the Somali fraud, which he never wants.
Never wants to Nick Shirley pick up his phone
and give a timestamp and date.
Basic journalism.
He's also never said a goddamn thing about Epstein.
Nothing, huh?
Nope, not one thing.
That's crazy, dude.
Nothing?
Nothing.
What else you want to know, bro?
Right, that's what I'm saying.
What else you want to know?
Jake Lang?
Jake Lang, heavily Jewish, in my opinion.
He's in pictures with the Teflon, the Teflon.
He's doing the rituals that they do.
To my understanding,
I think his sister served in forces over there.
Acting like he's a Christian.
In my opinion, he's not a Christian.
You can't preach what he's preaching
and call yourself a Christian.
We ambushed him with the Epstein sign.
Epstein wasn't Muslim.
And we exposed,
because why is he parading around like a Christian
trying to instigate hatred between Christians and Muslims?
That's what he's doing.
That's what he's trying to do.
Our film debunks it.
Go to the Sonny Faz channel.
S-O-N-N-Y-F-A-Z.
Check out the film.
Sonny, this one right here, this one?
We investigated the Muslim invasion of America.
It's right there.
Okay, cool.
Okay, we just got it back up.
Oh, this is the guy who just went
on Julian's show with you.
Yeah, we just got it back up.
And they took it down.
It was like a half a million views.
We just got it back up.
Go check out the film.
You're going to see for yourselves.
It's all fucking lies, Danny.
That's all I got to say.
My name's Beck Lover.
You can check me out on Instagram, at BE.
E-K, Lover, N-Y-C, or go to becklover.com.
Bitches.
Love you, bro.
Beck, you're the man.
Thank you so much.
This has been incredible.
Goodnight, world.